une production du studio SF
bienvenue sans filtre le
podcasts
cette semaine grand plaisir de recevoir
Nicolas Bérubé pour parler aujourd'hui
d'investissement en bourse de départ de
des finances personnelles de comment
devenir millionnaire parce qu'on sait
tous que c'est le but de la vie d'être
riche et d'améliana non mais là je fais
des job mais sans blague comment devenir
riche la richesse
le premier c'est les millionnaires ne
sont pas ceux que vous croyez qui sont
dernier c'est de 0 millionnaires
investir en bourse sans souffrir de zéro
millionnaire puis tu sais
le terme millionnaire ici veut pas de
récemment dire avoir les belles montres
la grande maison les gros chats ça veut
dire avoir une indépendance dans
certaines liberté c'est de dire avoir de
l'argent qui travaille pour nous tout
seul ça veut dire ne pas être endetté ça
veut dire
[Musique]
c'est sexy les rayeurs c'est sexy les
investissements en Bourse c'est un gros
un gros plus chaud certaines il y a
plusieurs de plusieurs podcasts qu'on
fait où est-ce que j'en ressors des
choses là on vient d'avoir la
conversation Le Play il y a plein de
choses qui me jouait à la tête pendant
cette conversation là puis maintenant
encore où est-ce que j'ai comme envie de
prendre l'action sur sur ce qui a été
dit parce que des concepts vraiment
frappants qui sont dits durant le
podcast puis on espère qu'ils vont vous
marquer autant quelques qu'il me marque
moi fait que sans plus attendre pour
podcast bonne écoute l'épisode de cette
semaine est présenté par la formation en
ligne vidéo créateur pro qui a été créé
par Niri et Henri de la compagnie de
production vidéo hxn c'est quoi ça en
fait c'est une formation gratuite de 45
minutes où est-ce les gars vous donnent
leur dix meilleurs astuces pour la
création de vidéos si vous êtes comme
moi moi j'ai une compagnie qui s'appelle
upika puis je porte absolument tous les
chapeaux de la compagnie dont celle de
créateur de contenu mais j'ai aucune
idée de comment ça fonctionne j'ai
aucune idée de comment tourner des beaux
vidéos de comment faire la promotion de
mon produit mais il faut que je la
prenne parce que c'est moi qu'il faut
qu'il fasse
une formation gratuite de 45 minutes où
est-ce que vous explique tout ça puis
pourquoi on les écouterait dans
on les connaît depuis longtemps en fait
un vidéo pour nous pour le studiosf un
vidéo promotionnel puis ils sont
vraiment chers et ils ont les ils ont
vraiment le don de la vidéo canalsa
c'est des pros notre vidéo était top
note si on fait et on travaille avec des
grandes compagnies comme sport comme la
Croix-Rouge comme wati ouais
c'est ça donc c'est des professionnels
du monde la vidéo puis là il donne enfin
leur truc pour pour tout le monde leurs
dix meilleurs astuces dans cette vidéo
là que donc vous soyez créateur de
contenu que vous soyez que vous ayez
votre propre business tout tourne autour
de la vidéo en 2023 il faut être capable
de contenu c'est le roi le contenu est
roi puis si les autres dans le fond leur
mission c'est de rendre le contenu
professionnel accessible à tous puis
vous le savez vous allez sauver
énormément d'argent si vous même vous
êtes capable de faire un contenu au look
professionnel je vais avoir plus
d'informations pour ça on va mettre le
lien dans la description du podcast et
honnêtement c'est gratuit 45 minutes
gratuit 10 astuces c'est débile allez
voir ça si ça vous intéresse puis merci
aux deux boys pour leur confiance
oui le podcast de cette semaine est
présenté par nos amis chez manscape on a
débattu avant d'enregistrer la publicité
à savoir si
Doom se coupait le poil de nez durant la
publicité mais on a jugé autrement à
cause qu'on est quand même dans notre
studio qu'on loue à des gens fait qu'on
a fait pas trop cochonner le studio mais
c'est ici le si vous avez des poils
donnés comme deux en ce moment c'est le
sujet
parce que là ça fait un boot que je l'ai
passé je les petits poils d'années qui
me sortent du nez ça m'agace ça me
dérange
c'est pas c'est ça un petit coup
d'amener
un produit vraiment formidable la
technologie skins SAF qui évite de se
faire mal de se couper quoi que ce soit
c'est vraiment une petite job clean et
vraiment parfaite si vous avez quelqu'un
dans votre vie qui a du bois le nez qui
dépasse c'est pas trop comment y
expliqué que son poids donné dépasse
puis que ça vous énerve acheter le
wiiwaker comme ça il va s'en rendre
compte par lui-même puis il va faire une
job extra clean et comme tous les
produits chez main Skype c'est de la
qualité et on le garantit parce qu'on
utilise ces produits là comme le gars
avec commenté l'autre fois dans les
messages oui c'est vrai on parle le
mansquée parce qu'il nous paye pour
parler de même Skype on en parlerait pas
sinon mais on utilise
et si vous avez vous voulez vous
procurer le will worker 2.0 ou n'importe
quelle autre produit chez manscape comme
le le
ultra smooth paquet
en plus que j'utilise honnêtement dans
ma vie de tous les jours je l'ai assez
dit mais je leur dis encore utiliser le
code promo sans filtre en un mot pour
20% de rabais le shipping gratuit et ils
vont savoir aussi que c'est nous qui
vous envoie faites utilise notre code
promo ça nous aide ça les aide ça vous
aide ça va être tout le monde on parle
de Polonais mais Paul d'oreille aussi si
vous connaissez des vous avez un
problème de poils d'oreille le Will Rock
You aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui on parle de d'investissement
on parle de finale d'argent finalement
avec toi tu écris deux livres sur le
sujet merci d'être là vraiment
aujourd'hui
je commence je plonge directement dans
le sujet en fait
là j'ai commencé j'ai pas euro de
terminer mais j'ai commencé ton dernier
livre puis tu racontes un peu c'est
comment tu t'intéresser à ce sujet-là
puis c'est quoi tes premières
expériences puis je trouve que
l'histoire est quand même vraiment bonne
et je me demandais cette tentait un peu
de lui faire un peu justement la genèse
de tout ça le commente tu as commencé à
t'intéresser aux investissements puis
les premières
erreurs que tu as fait maintenant je
trouve ça bon intéressant on va devoir
présenter aussi un introduction faite
[Rires]
tu l'as dit c'est exactement ça j'ai
commencé avec une erreur c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment universel je te dirais
presque tu sais les gens qui
s'intéressent à la Bourse ils vont tout
te le dire quand on s'intéresse au
placement de ça on finit par piler sur
un savon puis plutôt que tard d'habitude
puis moi en fait c'est que dans ma
vingtaine j'ai bon je travaille je
commençais à la presse à 25 ans puis à
29 j'ai été nommé correspondant qu'elle
fournit puis à ce moment Californie ça
vient avec un plus gros salaire c'est
tout un salaire de correspondant donc
c'est un peu plus haut que journaliste
puis en plus de ça j'avais une prime à
la vie chère parce que la vie Californie
plus cher qu'en Montréal donc comme un
bureau de contact qui dit ça coûte 19 %
plus cher donc vous payez 19% en plus
chose demain donc là j'ai dit ok
j'approche de 30 ans c'est pas vrai que
je vois tout dépenser ça au restaurant
puis c'est faire le nounou puis je
voulais faire quelque chose d'adulte
entre guillemets
ça va être facile de dépenser ça en
cours de yoga puis en latte et puis ce
que tu veux
c'est pas les occasions qui manquent là
c'est donc là
mais je voulais quand même vraiment
mettre l'argent de côté en fait c'est
pas fait ça vraiment avant ça puis là je
me suis dit la bourse donc la bourse
qu'est-ce que c'est dans ma tête c'est
un gros casino
il faut que tu mets sur la prochaine
compagnie qui va faire qui va être super
hot c'est donc ça et moi ben ça c'était
à l'époque en fait vers quand j'ai
commencé à placer c'était vers 2008 2009
dans ce blush s'il y en a souvent
c'était un gros crash après la bulle
immobilière américain donc moi ma grande
théorie de génie c'était que en fait
c'est que la bourse elle avait baissé
énormément durant le crash mais tout de
suite après elle a remonter presque en V
en fait alors monter vraiment vite
vraiment haut puis si les gens que je
lisais sur internet ça les gens disaient
c'est pas c'est un peu une feinte c'est
pas vraiment une remontée puis je voyais
autour de moi tu sais les gens perdaient
leur maison les gens perdaient leur
travail tout c'était vraiment j'écrivais
là dessus donc c'était comme je
comprenais pas ce que vous voyez autour
de moi puisque la bourse faisait ça
faisait aucun sens donc je me suis dit
c'est sûr que c'est pas fini c'est donc
en fait ce que j'ai acheté c'est les
options de vente là bon je vais faire
une histoire courte c'est des produits
financiers qui sont transigés à la
Bourse et qui prennent de la valeur
quand la bourse chute donc c'est
l'inverse donc moi
c'est ça que j'ai fait je le dis à mon
lit j'ai investi à peu près 10000
dollars là-dedans c'est ce qui était un
gros montant qui dresse un gros montant
c'est pas c'est pas rien et je l'ai
perdu en trois mois à peu près
jamais c'est terminé je viens de
gaspiller 10000 pièces ça représentait
dessus c'était ce statut mettons sans
vouloir plonger dans ton compte
personnel mais ça représentait dessus
comme une grosse partie des économies ou
c'est bonne partie en fait j'avais
acheté un duplex avec un ami puis on
l'avait rénové pour l'avait vendu le
profit que j'avais fait c'est à peu près
10000 dollars ok donc j'ai toutes
l'effort que j'ai mis dans cette
building là puis le stress il est coupé
téléphone puis tout ça c'est un peu
parti de même là ça m'a j'ai eu
l'impression de dire certains échelle
sur un certain temps c'est assez
humiliant tout ça donc à ce moment-là et
puis là j'ai la misère à me l'expliquer
encore aujourd'hui mais c'est
normalement
que j'aurais dû faire parce que moi j'ai
pas quelqu'un qui a un background en
finance je sais pas je parlais au HEC je
sais pas c'est pas comme je sais pas ce
gars normalement ce que j'aurais dû
faire c'est claquer la porte pizza moi
je touche pas à ça c'est les petits
poissons je remets de chance et les gros
poissons qui font de l'argent mais je
sais pas encore d'où c'est venu mais
cette expérience là m'a fait me plonger
encore plus là-dedans mais je voulais
comprendre comment ça il y en a qui s'en
sort bien c'est comme quelqu'un comme
Warren Buffett c'est qu'on entend à
gauche à droite un peu tout le temps
quand on lit là-dessus mais en anglais
85 ans 90 ans puis lui il y a pas là
d'avoir c'est quoi je dois une façon
pour quelqu'un qui a le bon tempérament
soit donc
une question de chance si c'est tout le
temps les mêmes qui font de l'argent si
quelqu'un qui sent bon à ça fait
constamment un peu comme le poker où
est-ce que tu dis ok pourquoi tout le
temps genre la table des 8 finalistes
pourquoi tout le temps 4 que je connais
dans les mannequins donc eux ils ont
peut-être compris quelque chose que les
800 autres qui sont pas à cette table là
ont pas compris donc là je me suis mis à
tirer le fil par lire c'est une coupe de
livres là-dessus des classiques tout ça
c'est là que j'ai compris dans le fond
que c'est c'est vraiment pas un casino
et puis c'est normal puis aujourd'hui
j'entends les gens quand je parle de ce
sujet-là les gens vont dire ah toi tu
joues à la Bourse puis à toutes les fois
ça c'est comme un tableau noir parce que
c'est pas un jeu c'est ça l'affaire puis
je comprends d'où vient la question
c'est normal je dis notre société voit
ça comme un gros casino puis si tu t'es
pas trop intéressé à ça tu vois ça de
l'extérieur comme un gros casino tu veux
pas y toucher tu sais mais quand tu
t'intéresses la bourse ça existe depuis
plus de 400 ans tu sais donc c'est pas
comme c'est un peu comme 30 ans le
combien comme d'habitude c'est pas la
crypto le titre donc il y a quelque
chose c'est assez universel il y a une
bonne fiche de route si on peut on peut
comprendre les bons comportements qu'on
peut comprendre les mauvais
comportements donc il y a de la matière
c'est pour ça que des fois je trouve la
bourse à retire les mauvaises personnes
en quelque part parce que tu sais les
gens qui engimaient sont pas à l'argent
un avantage par rapport à ceux qui sont
à l'argent parce ceux qui sont à
l'argent il peut pas s'empêcher de voir
ça comme un casino mais ceux qui sont
pas l'argent des gens qui gagnent même
pas tant d'argent que ça dans la vie tu
sais mais si tu prends une petite partie
ton argent puis tu l'investis de la
bonne façon tu peux m'en parler mais tu
as un avantage dans mon premier livre
j'ai intervie des gens qui ont étudié en
théâtre
des gens qui qui sont des pigistes des
gens qui jamais qui pensent à l'engin
c'est justement parce que tu penses pas
à l'argent tu as un avantage par rapport
à la personne qui veut faire son choix
avec une belle voiture puis qui veut
être impressionné avec ces stocks tu
veux faire de l'argent rapidement
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
intéressant ce concept là parce que puis
on peut entrer dans quels sont les
bonnes pratiques de ce que tu viens de
dire que les gens qui sont pas à
l'argent un avantage
parce qu'au fond de ce que j'en
comprends c'est un long game
l'investissement en bourse c'est ça se
passe sur longtemps puis il faut que
ton tempérament soit une douce rivière
qui coule tranquillement j'imagine pour
être capable de résister au et au bas de
voir ton 10000 pièces disparaître pour
revenir ensuite c'est ça donc c'est
comment ça s'articule une bonne pratique
de quelqu'un qui est investisse en
bourse comme moi la bourse c'est un
mécanisme qui transfère les actifs des
Impatients aux patients c'est donc si tu
étais vraiment
donc en fait bon pour revenir à ce que
je disais tantôt c'est pas un casino
quand je dis c'est pas occasion dans le
sens que c'est pas l'idée d'aller
chercher l'aiguille dans la botte de
foin parce que souvent c'est les gens
âges analysé tel à faire là c'est le
lithium qui va être bien l'année
prochaine puis était la petite compagnie
mon ami est ingénieur minier et puis me
parler d'une compagnie qui est en
Afrique en ce moment qui la personne la
connaît mais attends à 25 ans mais elle
va être à 8200 dans 6 mois ça tu ris
parce que c'est une anecdote c'est la
seule anecdote que j'ai par rapport à
bourse par rapport à mes parents si mon
père qui avait déjà eu un genre de cul
de même ça fait rien de ne pas tout je
pense que pour toucher à bourse après
autre chose avec son argent mais pas
seul mais c'est souvent ça souvent les
gens ils essaient ça ça marche pas il
large puis bon mais bref c'est dans le
fond la bonne approche c'est de voir ça
plutôt comme au lieu d'aller chercher
l'aiguille il faut que tu achètes la
botte de foin au complet donc acheter la
bonne question d'avoir l'aiguille exact
parce que c'est ça historiquement les
les marchés ont été tirés vers le haut
par à peu près 4% des compagnies cotées
à la Bourse
donc c'est très très difficile de passer
à côté puis les quatre pour ça son pas
toujours évidentes parce que là si je
demande aujourd'hui aux gens bon c'est
ça c'est quoi les 4 % mais là tout le
monde peut les nommer mais il y a 20 ans
personne personne n'aurait par exemple
nommé à Paul il faisait des des
ordinateurs pour les graphismes qui
étaient deux fois plus cher que les les
autres ordinateurs donc c'était pas des
gens il allume pas dans ton livre là on
voit justement les le top 20 de 20 ans
puis le Top 20 aujourd'hui puis je pense
que une compagnie qui qui love le 20 ans
qui est encore là aujourd'hui donc ça
change vraiment rapidement exact la
compagnie c'est Microsoft qui pendant 15
ans Microsoft absolument rien fait comme
l'action elle a pas bougé à 15 ans à
cause de la grosse bulle techno des
années 2000 donc pendant que c'est
aujourd'hui on est là mais oui c'est sûr
si tu avais acheté Microsoft il y a 15
ans il y a 20 ans il y a 30 ans tu
serais riche oui mais pendant 15 ans là
tu aurais stressé peut-être moyen
pourquoi j'ai ça ça vaut rien tu sais
donc moi c'est ce que je trouve
intéressant avec la bourse c'est que ça
vient vraiment l'esprit humain est pas
fait pour investir l'esprit humain c'est
quasiment le contraire c'est vraiment
comme la gravité va nous attirer au
plafond c'est comme vraiment il faut se
retirer c'est toutes nos réflexes puis
notre gode feeling ça nous amène pas
dans la bonne direction donc moi c'est
la partie intéressante mais bref pour
pour revenir à ça c'est dans le fond
acheter la botte de fond complet et puis
ça il y a des produits qui sont qui
existent depuis c'est une quarantaine
cinquantaine d'années un peu moins au
Canada mais qui s'appelle des fonds
négociants en bourse FNB ça c'est fond
là dans le fond c'est ça c'est la botte
de foin complet c'est le marché au
complet que tu achètes quand tu achètes
un seul fond là
historiquement les gens ont pas fait ça
les gens ont fait comme on parle tantôt
du stockpk moi j'achète Ji j'achète je
sais pas quoi il y a quelques années tel
cannabis
ça s'arrête pas toujours une mode il y a
toujours quelque chose qui est bien mais
pendant pandémie c'était zoom peloton
une pleine compagnies comme ça donc
toujours une mode il y a toujours ça
mais cette technique-là permet un peu
d'ignorer les modes d'ignorer puis quand
tu passais le marché au complet tu t'en
fous de savoir si qui le prochain gros
quartier comme Tesla tu l'as mais tu
avais pas le prévoir il est dans ton
fond donc c'est ça la faire parce que
les prévisions de bourse c'est n'importe
quoi c'est vraiment c'est pire que
l'astrologie ok quand tu t'intéresses à
ça pire que l'astruction
d'investir dans mercure
de la personne qui disait oui mais moi
mon chum il y a investi dans le cannabis
il y a 75000 pièces nananas qu'est-ce
qu'on répond c'est en fait c'est de
l'anecdote qui c'est probablement vrai
sauf que c'est sur les terrains de Gold
c'est les les bons les bons coups que
les gens se disent tu sais c'est la
pointe du iceberg c'est tout le reste en
dessous les mauvais coups ils sont pas
sur les tarengols c'est parce que c'est
pas le faire
donc oui
une minute trouette
sur Facebook
il est tellement
honteux d'avoir perdu son 10000 pièces
en investissant dans quelque chose qui
pensait que lui tu ne l'entends pas
parler de ça j'entends pas parler de ton
exemple de quand même moi j'ai un ami
qui a perdu 30 000 pièces maintenant
dans une mine au Japon là dans les gens
souvent soit ils calculent pas soit il
en parle pas ou c'est bon donc oui il y
a toujours des actions qui vont super
bien faire d'un court terme et tout
fois plus d'eau après ça moins 33 c'est
très très rare pour ça qu'il faut que tu
ailles une vision super long terme parce
que le -33 il fait mal et si tu le
regardes ton compte c'est ça
ou tu as des centaines de compagnies
là-dedans ça fluctue autant que ça ouais
ça c'est quand ton fond là c'est pour la
bourse parce que dans le fond
l'investissement les actifs financiers
il y a au moins deux catégories
d'investissement que les gens devraient
deux catégories d'actifs les gens
devraient avoir c'est les actions donc
ça c'est 9% Canada aux États-Unis c'est
un peu plus c'est peut-être 11 % à peu
près depuis une cinquantaine d'années
pour mettons pour les gens qui sont
complètement néophytes les actions
l'enfant c'est que tu achètes une petite
partie d'une compagnie finalement
Apple dans le fond
des millions d'actions puis toi ben
quand tu achètes le fond dont je parle
le FNB mais tu as une petite partie des
250 plus grandes compagnies au Canada ou
une petite partie des 500 plus grandes
compagnies aux États-Unis qui est la SNP
500 donc avec un seul un seul fond
extrêmement diversifié parce qu'il y a
plein de domaines là dedans ces
technologies produit de consommation
shampoing de voiture tout ce que tu veux
donc vraiment il y a des tu as vraiment
comme grande diversification ce que tu
as pas quand tu achètes une compagnie
une compagnie la compagnie va mal
tes prix avec mais bon alors alors donc
ça c'est une partie d'actifs ça c'est
les montagnes russes c'est la Bourse et
les montagnes russes parce que une année
ça peut faire plus 30 - 30 ça très peu
de gens sont capables d'avoir tous leurs
actifs là-dedans il y en a qui sont
capables mais c'est très très difficile
psychologiquement surtout que un 2020
arrive puis là ça part 33 % un mois
on avait reçu Jean-Martin sortant de la
pandémie puis lui nous avait dit le
meilleur investissement durant la
dernière année d'avoir de l'argent tout
son oreiller
aussi
dans le sens où après la pandémie ça
tellement craché que comme si tu as de
l'argent c'est paniquant versus dort
dessus au moins de ceux qui est là sauf
que si les gens se rappellent pas c'est
que 2020 quelle année du gros crash
pandémie c'est une année qui est
terminée en hausse donc si tu es tombé
dans le coma le premier janvier 2020
c'était réveillé le premier janvier
20218 ou 9 %
ok parce que c'est dans le fond la
bourse si tu vends pas tu réalises
aucune perte c'est juste c'est juste un
chiffre là
moi mes parents ont tout perdu dans le
crash de 2008 on met la crash de 2008
ils ont tout perdu parce qu'ils ont
vendu c'est parce que c'était temporaire
ça remonte c'est la bourse a fait x 2 x
3 depuis 2008
c'est pour ça que les personnes qui s'y
intéressent le moins comme je vous
expliquais tantôt ont un avantage par
rapport à la personne qui se lève le
matin qui ouvre son téléphone
donc déjà là tu étais plus dans le
comportement de day trading puis tout ça
le plus tu t'éloignes de ça c'est plus à
longtemps tu as un avantage donc dans le
fond les fonds pour un peu tempéré
justement les le plus 30 - 30 et tout il
y a une autre catégorie d'artifs qui
s'appelle les obligations les
obligations en France c'est juste prêter
de l'argent à un gouvernement ou une
entreprise qui te remettent ton argent
avec de l'intérêt donc c'est c'est comme
j'avais déjà dans une chronique c'est si
ça a l'air plat oui c'est plate donc
c'est vraiment la partie plate ça c'est
la partie blé entier de ton portefeuille
l'autre c'est la partie plus le fun mais
si la partie blé entier te permet de
rester sain d'esprit dans une chute
boursière c'est si le marché chute
mettons de 30 mais toi à cause de tes
obligations qui baissent moins en fait
les obligations baisse beaucoup moins
ils montent moins mais baisse moi donc
ça peut t'aider dans une année comme de
covid
toi tu as peut-être baissé de 12 % tu
sais alors que le marché de 30 donc là
tu dis ok c'est pas pire si je suis
capable de bien dormir quand même et
puis il y a un vieux dicton qui dit on
achète des actions pour bien manger on a
acheté les obligations pour bien dormir
c'est un peu c'est un peu l'explication
de c'est quoi ces produits là et
aujourd'hui il y a des fonds négociants
en bourse qui possèdent ces deux
catégories là dans le même font donc
c'est vraiment tout en un tu as juste
besoin d'acheter un fond tu achète une
affaire puis toi tu as parti en fond le
fond se décline en différentes variantes
là 80 disons 80% action 20% obligation
ensuite 60 40 donc plus de plus
d'obligations moins tu vas avoir de
rendement mais plus tu es quelqu'un
d'Autrement nerveux tu es mieux d'y
aller je prends avec des obligations
c'est ça puis à la fin je pense qu'il y
a 60 60 % obligations 40% action mais ça
je recommande pas ça à une personne qui
est retraités ou quoi que ce soit c'est
bon parce que il y a aussi à travers
tout ça si on part du risque mais il y a
un risque dont on parle jamais c'est le
risque de manquer d'argent dans le vide
parce que les gens oh le risque tout ça
le marché futur oui mais
si tu as gagné une affaire que 10% de ta
paye qui s'en est à chaque fois dans ton
fond puis que en étant besoin de 10% là
tu es fait
tu peux faire un choix à ce que je vends
mes actions avec un peu de chance tu vas
avoir mis ta paie assez d'années que
l'argent que tu as besoin comme pour
acheter un nouveau frigo n'importe quoi
ça va être un petit pourcentage de tes
actifs puis ça on peut parler mais ça
donne un super pouvoir c'est parce que
ce qui arrive dans nos sociétés c'est
que les gens ils dépensent en premier
puis épargne ensuite
les intérêts embarquent donc c’était
capable de faire l'inverse d'épargner en
premier puis dépenser ensuite si tu vas
toujours être avantagé par rapport à la
personne qui fait pas ça puis merci
mon premier livre en fait les
millionnaires sont pas ceux que vous
croyez tu peux faire monologue c'est pas
mal seul l'idée là
on va poser des questions
mais c'est ça c'est que en fait faire un
peu une tangente vers un peu le style de
vie c'est que
pour mon premier livre j'ai interviewé
des 12 millionnaires québécois et
canadien et un milliardaire c'est sur
leur finance puis comment ici si on prie
comment ils ont pris ils ont abordé les
choses c'est qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait
différemment de monsieur madame tout le
monde
je fais des petites parenthèses
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui détermine
une personne humiliaire comment qu'on
comment qu'on le calcul ben il y aura
enfin il y a deux façons c'est la
piscine de Picsou là
il y a une piscine hors pair remplie de
billets
mais en fait bonne question c'est que en
fait c'est les c'est les actifs les
actifs moi le passif donc c'est ce que
tu possèdes moins tu es bête donc c'est
une maison qui vaut 500 000 mais tu as
une hypothèque de 400 000 dessus ben
c'est ta valeur nette c'est 100000 il y
en a dans la valeur qui inclut l'actif
la maison principale il y en a qui
l'inclient pas pour faire plus simple on
inclut donc moi dans mon livre j'ai
inclus la valeur la maison principale la
résidence principale mais c'est dans
tous les cas c'était une petite partie
de leur valeur déjà
et donc c'est ça je me suis intéressé en
fait à ça après avoir eu un livre
américain qui s'appelle de Millionaire
next door qui était publié des années 90
puis
c'est des chercheurs universitaires aux
États-Unis qui ont voulu faire un espèce
de portrait des millionnaires américains
et puis quand ils ont commencé leur
recherche ils sont allés dans les gros
quartiers avec les grosses maisons puis
de ça puis ils sont rendus compte ils
vont faire remplir des questionnaires
aux gens qui sont rendus compte que
souvent les gens qui sont là des gros
revenus mais des grosses dates des
grosses dépenses puis il reste pas
vraiment entre les deux puis au final
quand tu fais la colonne des divers pas
de la colonne du rouge il est pas en
haut d'un million là
même si la maison elle vaut 1 parce que
c'est une grosse hypothèque mais tu l'as
pas l'argent là c'est pas réellement ta
maison au complet
et ils sont rendus compte en faisant
leurs études que beaucoup de gens qui
habitaient dans les quartiers qui sont
même pas des quartiers cossus était un
millionnaire donc il y a vraiment des
gens de la classe moyenne classement
moyenne élevé c'est là que tu vas aller
trouver le noyau parce que oui il y en a
des riches qui habitent dans les
quartiers riches parce que de dire mais
tu vas aller chercher vraiment les gens
c'est qui qui ont plus d'un million en
actifs la majorité ils sont dans les
quartiers de la classe moyenne classe
moyenne élevée ils ont des des trains de
vie qui sont pas vraiment différents de
leurs voisins ou tu as une voiture ou
deux il y a une piscine d'encours ils
vont dans le sud de l'hiver et ont comme
une vie qu'on pourrait calculer de
classes moyennes classe moyenne élevé
sauf que au lieu d'être enseveli de
dettes ils ont un point 2 un point 6 2
millions à 45 ans 50 ans c'est la maison
a payé donc là moi je voulais savoir
comment ces gens le pensent et qu'est-ce
qui ont fait que des gens qui sont
partis à peu près au même niveau sur les
bancs d'écoles ont évolué de façon
tellement différente puis dans le fond
c'est ce que ces gens-là ont fait je
trouve ça intéressant de vous parler
puis parler aux gens qui écoutent le
podcast c'est que tout commence à la
vingtaine parce qu'on a l'impression que
la vingtaine a ben là je peux pas
vraiment beaucoup d'argent je dois faire
de l'argent peut-être dans 10-15 ans
tout va bien
pourquoi je me soucierais de ça c'est
pas vraiment c'est mais quand tu es
jeune tu as du temps comme on le dit
avec les placements financiers c'est
avec le temps tu sais que c'était
placement font 9 % par année ou
peut-être un petit peu moins parce que
tu mets pas tout en action là ça c'est
vraiment à chaque fois que tu fais tu
fais c'est que tes placements double
petit tripes quadruple mais c'est sur le
long terme que ça se fait donc la
personne de 20 ans qui met c'est
l'équivalent d'un paiement de voiture
mettons je parle de mettre de l'argent
de côté les gens je peux pas je peux pas
je peux pas puis 2 secondes après son
réseau concessionnaire puis ils viennent
de s'acheter une voiture
quoi c'est c'est mais l'équivalent ça
c'est comme socialement accepté d'avoir
d'aller au concessionnaire dans une
voiture neuve alors que quand on y pense
de secondes
c'est des gens qui dépensent presque
leur salaire annuel dans un voiture
c'est fou c'est donc c'est capoté là
juste une mini parenthèse sur ce dossier
là parce que en préparation pour le
podcast j'ai écouté ton passage sur sur
quelques podcasts
notamment liberté 45 je pense ouais
je réfléchissais à quelqu'un qu'est-ce
que genre
qui nous écoutent qui se pose la même
question là surtout ces jours-ci où
est-ce que toute vraiment cher là
puis finalement ma location de voiture a
termine afin de ce mois-ci puis là je
rachète ma voiture au résiduel parce que
c'est le meilleur deal que je peux avoir
pour un char à ce moment-ci là je
l'avais je l'avais commencé dans le fond
avant la pandémie bref je l'avais eu
vraiment un bon deal puis là c'est le
meilleur deal que je peux faire mais là
je me suis dit le
200 pièces par deux semaines le 220
pièces par deux semaines qui va dans mon
char fait que le 440 pièces par mois je
vais continuer à le payer mais je vais
je vais l'investir à place tu sais je
vais continuer à le faire sortir parce
que je l'ai budgétais dans mon affaire
mais je dis mais je vais le placer à
place ça va je vais continuer parce que
là je vais montrer une vie qui est
capable de fonctionner avec ce paiement
là qui passe là j'aurais pu supprimer là
mais je vais le mettre là à place c'est
tellement de l'argent dans le fond quand
tu penses à ça exactement donc il y a
des pays où trouver de la place mais ça
ramène quand tu es jeune ok souvent ce
qui arrive c'est que les gens quand ils
ont leur premier vrai travail après les
études métaux là ils vont faire comment
ça faire un salaire papier ou pas pire
selon par rapport à ce qu'il faisait
avant qu'est-ce que j'envoie faire on
dit ok là j'ai moi j'ai des couleurs
mais là je peux me permettre je parle
tout seul ou bien je m'achète un condo
ok bon je vois tu traîner mes vieux
meubles dans mon nouveau condo je vais
acheter une machine
ok bon là ma voiture 2012 ouais 2012 pas
super ok ta ta voiture ah qu'est-ce tu
fais ah c'est la relâche que tu fais bah
je sais pas on va dans le sud ah ouais
ok donc finalement tu finis que ton
train de vie augmente mais tu es aussi
serré que quand tu faisais un plus petit
salaire puis ça
tu vas toujours être serré même si tu
fais un salaire qui est objectivement
les deux trois quatre fois plus donc si
au début de la vingtaine ce que je dis
là peut-être les gens vont écouter votre
classement je m'en fous puis c'est pas
ça que je veux vivre puis Yolo pizza ok
ça me décharge vraiment ma vie mais il y
a un pourcentage puis moi j'aurais été
susceptible de
d'adhérer à ça dans le fond parce que
j'étais pas vraiment matérialiste je
courais pas après les belles choses mais
des gens comme moi c'est moi j'ai jamais
entendu ce discours là quand j'avais 20
ans personne ne m'a jamais dit ça donc
c'est pour ça en fait que moi si j'en
fais si les gens qui je m'adresse un peu
ces gens-là c'est qui qui vont comme tu
sais qui ont fait des études qui m'ont
quand même bien gagner leur vie qui ont
pas vraiment de plantes déterminés avec
l'argent de ça mais il y a un avantage à
rouler en Toyota 2013 là par rapport à
un auto de l'année puis c'est avantage
là comme tu le dis c'est d'aller
chercher un 400 500 pièces par mois OK
puis là au lieu de le mettre en voiture
tu le mets justement dans tes placements
mais si tu commences à 20 ans tu étais
millionnaire dans sa quantaine ok donc
là les gens vont dire ok 50 ans dans 30
ans oui sauf que partout chaque année en
cours de route c'est les avantages
d'épargner ils sont pas juste dans 30
ans ils sont dans un an dans deux ans
parce que justement quand tu as un
imprévu comme tu mentionnel donne un
imprévu que j'étais un frigo tout ça
bang ok donc là tu règles sans une
seconde alors que la personne à côté qui
fait pas ça elle va prendre un plan de
financement
on va le payer deux fois le prix sur un
parce que à l'époque prévu donc c'est
l'avantage en fait il faut pas passer à
la retraite moi j'ai jamais vu ça comme
ça j'ai toujours pensé à
travailler pour justement pour moi-même
puis avoir peu importe ce que tu sois
entrepreneur ou que tu travailles
fonctionnaire ou travailler plus un
salarié si tu mets l'argent de côté puis
c'est ça qui est millionnaire qui j'ai
parlé me disait il dit ça fait baisser
le stress parce qu'il y arrive quelque
chose comme l'inflation puis là il y en
a pas de problème c'est si tu as besoin
d'aller chercher de l'argent tu vas puis
ça va représenter avec un peu de chance
une petite partie de tes actifs
qui t'arrive au courant de la vie tu as
besoin d'une auto ok il y en a plein
d'auto sur Marketplace ou les packs quoi
que ce soit 10 12000 15000 dollars mais
les gens ont pas 15000 dollars mais déjà
de mon âge là moi j'ai 46 ans qui se
fait 21 ans que je travaille c'est pour
la presse 21h que je garde un guillemets
bien ma vie c'est parler standard puis
il y a des gens qui ont un même parcours
que moi mais ils n'ont pas 10 000 pièces
tu l'aurais remis aux autres ok mais ça
c'est un choix de le remettre aux autres
puis dans le fond ça revient un peu à la
définition de la richesse c'est la
richesse on a toujours l'impression que
c'est
extérieur à nous ces gens hop moi je
suis graphiste je suis pas médecin
spécialiste donc la richesse ça me parle
pas
ou bien ah moi la richesse c'est si je
travaillais chez concurrent et j'aurais
15% de plus de salaire là j'aurais le
choix riche mais dans le fond la
richesse c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche c'est vraiment de l'intérieur
c'est comme c'est toi en fait qui décide
de commencer à bâtir ta richesse c'est
que tu sois salam minimum puis bon je
vais pas faire l'autruche là que c'est
sûr que plus mieux tu gagnes ta vie plus
que tu une marge de manœuvre c'est sûr
c'était en mode survie c'était en mode
survie mais
il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont
justement pas en mode survie tu sais qui
ont qui ont du LOSC qui ont un paiement
de char qui ont des choses comme ça puis
avec les connaissances mais seulement en
application tu sais certaines Forget là
tu l'oublies là c'est là que ça fait des
des c'est moi les gens que j'ai parlé il
y en a qui ont payé c'est au lieu
d'acheter leur maison à 22 ans mais ils
l'ont acheté plus tard dans la vie mais
là il y avait un méchant dans le
paiement là méchant de mise de fond pour
faire ça ou la voiture ils ont acheté
une voiture neuve à 12 13000 pièces puis
c'est fini on puis de paiement plus rien
c'est ça parce qu'à chaque fois que tu
as une dépense à faire si tu as le cash
pour la faire tu payes pas d'intérêt
dessus dans le fond ça c'est énorme bah
c'est énorme puis il y en a tu sais il y
a une personne sur trois des cartes de
crédit traînent une balance de moi en
moi
je l'ai déjà fait je veux dire je sais
pas c'est pas c'est pas je le parle dans
mon lit je parle de mes erreurs puis
c'est même boire une Buffett on a fait
des erreurs dans sa vington il y a perdu
un tiers 20% je pense de ces de ces
revenus dans un mauvais placement de ça
donc tout le monde c'est toujours poils
se rend compte que c'est chaud mais
c'est ce que tu fais après dans le fond
et c'est moi un peu mon message c'est
que si on gagne très bien notre vie dans
le sens nous la société en général si tu
regardes un graphique c'est de comment
les gens gagnent leur vie c'est au
niveau de l'histoire du Québec la
meilleure année là c'est 2023
c'est pas 1960 à sortez-vous ça de la
tête là c'est c'est maintenant donc le
revenu est là le taux de chômage il est
à peu près à un bas qui a jamais été
donc pourquoi les gens sont si pris à la
gorge mais c'est parce que nos vies sont
tellement opulentes et remplies de
l'expérience de voyage de resto de pas
encore là pour tout le monde je sais que
des gens en mode survie des gens qui ont
des dettes d'études des choses comme ça
mais
quand une personne il met son attention
pitié c'est ça dépend aussi comment tu
vois ta dette si tu vois ça comme une
espèce de
une bonne façon de voir la chose aussi
ce que tu viens de dire là c'est
frappant quand même comme image le
dessus tu gères pas ta dette tu te votes
à toi-même un salaire moins élevé parce
qu'il y a une partie de ton salaire qui
s'en va danser ça tu pries tout à fait
puis même à faire avec un c'est vrai une
voiture neuve pick-up neuf genre de
choses là tu dois être une base de
salaire piquante tu trouves que ton
salaire est passé élevé à job mais
toi-même tu te le diminues tu te le
diminue volontairement c'est intéressant
comme vision ça puis aussi c'est ça ça
remonte aussi à l'investissement c'est
quand c'est parce que tu comprends que
l'argent c'est pas juste des points
c'est moi pendant longtemps pour moi
l'argent c'était comme des points c'est
comme ah je veux m'acheter une part de
ski ça coûte 800 points j'ai 800 points
dans mon compte je donne mais l'argent
c'est pas des points l'argent c'est des
travailleurs ça peut travailler pour toi
si moi j'ai de l'argent qui travaille
pour moi aujourd'hui que j'ai gagné en
qui travaille encore pour moi pendant
qu'on se parle là donc c'est ça un peu
l'idée c'est que une fois que tu as
compris ça c'est un pouvoir cet
argent-là c'est un pouvoir qui peut
prendre la forme d'un objet que tu peux
acheter maintenant ou dans le futur mais
c'est un pouvoir qui peut prendre la
forme d'une année sabbatique
qui peut prendre la forme de d'une
retraite plutôt des gens qui sait
combien il y en a des gens qui sont à 5
ans 10 ans la retraite sont plus
capables ils regardent le calendrier ah
non c'est ma prison dorée oui j'ai des
menottes d'horri bla bla des personnes
qui t'a mis ces menottes là mais j'ai la
personne qui a 100 000 un million de
placés personne là a pu travailler à
temps partiel un peu se réorienter
travailler dans une jambe moins payante
mais c'est pas vraiment grave parce que
à le désactive donc quand tu le vois
comme ça c'est pas juste du c'est du
bling bling Louis Vuitton
c'est que tu peux aller te chercher etc
donc c'est vraiment une liberté
donc moi c'est ça le fait de le voir
comme ça
ce qui est génial c'est qu'à un moment
donné au bout de 10 15 ans 20 ans et tu
regardes tes placements tu fais rien à
mes placements gagne plus d'argent que
moi c'est comme si vous étiez deux à
travailler ok donc ça ça c'est à la
portée de plus de monde qu'on pense
de faire ces placements-là puis encore
là ça fait baisser le stress ça fait il
y a quand même une récession qui arrive
une perte d'emploi tu peux te retourner
le bar puis tu es moins stressé donc
c'est un peu ça moi j'ai découvert
guillemets avec mes recherches mais mes
entrevues mais les livres que j'ai écrit
ça tombe un peu autour de ça tu sais les
oui est-ce qu'il faut sacrifier des
choses est-ce qu'il faut en guillemets
se priver tout dépend de comment tu vois
ça c'est sûr que la personne qui a pris
l'habitude d'aller au restaurant toutes
les soirs qui est rendu à mon âge mais
là wow attends là je vais me priver
c'est bon mais c'est pour ça que c'est
comme un jeune à 20 ans tes habitudes
sont pas encore
tu peux faire un choix de la voiture que
tu veux tu peux faire un choix des gens
de voyage que tu veux les restos ça peut
être une fois par mois ça peut être une
fois par semaine c'est tout peut changer
donc la personne qui comprend ça à peu
faire un choix un peu différent de la
masse en guillemets mais le résultat va
être vachement différent de ce que tout
le monde a parce que tu vas lire tout le
monde est stressé tout le monde est pris
à la gorge tout le monde mais toi tu
seras pas ça donc c'est pas pris le sera
pas pris là tu seras pas pris dans le
trap de sable à stresser pour des choses
qui devrait objectivement pas être
stressante des gens qui gagnent c'est
bien leur vie ils devraient être capable
de me dire 15-20% de témoins comment je
vois ça c'est
donc sur les cinq jours dans une semaine
il y en a quatre que je travaille pour
mes besoins actuels puis la cinquième je
m'enrichis donc juste en faisant ça
ton salaire exact puis la façon dont je
le vois si j'étais aux gens même c'est
pour ça paye le côté quoi tu fous voyons
donc ok mais je te dis il y a 4 jours
dans la semaine que tu travailles pour
toi maintenant puis le cinquième tu
t'enrichex cette journée là c'est comme
logique c'est bon
puis notre société est un peu extrême
sans sa rendre compte parce que dans le
fond si tout le monde est extrême
personne n'est extrait un petit donc à
fond c'est juste de se dire attends là
je dépense 100% de ma paye c'est
vraiment extrême c'est historiquement
c'est du jamais vu le truc qui ont fait
ça les humains c'est c'est mon
grand-parents
ça serait le restera jamais venu à
l'idée de dépenser ça dépend
c'est la norme mais je pense c'est
que les gens mettent de côté mais donc
si tu le mets
tu fais monter l'aiguille un peu tire au
lieu du 3%, tu le mets à 10 à 15 à 20 là
tu as vraiment un avantage puis il y a
des gens il y a le mouvement fireers pas
si vous entendez parler c'est final
early donc fire la chronique et ça dans
le fond c'est exactement ce que je dis
mais l'aiguille au lieu de la mettre à
10 ou à 15%, il y a des gens qui le
mettent à 50 60 % c'est généralement
plus facile de faire un couple je dirais
imagine un couple c'est les deux un bon
salaire tu vis sur un salaire tu sauves
l'autre
cela c'est comme ça
tu pourras prendre ta retraite quelqu'un
qui mettait à 25 ans commence à
travailler avec un un salaire correct si
tu sauves 50% de ton salaire donc
mettons que tu vis tu vis humblement
finalement le titre de ton paiement de
loyer puis tu vas pas au resto puis tu
peux y aller au resto au-dessus c'est
juste ça mais tu vas peut-être choisir
tes batailles mais oui mais mettons tu
préfères un 15 ans en guillemets de
stérilité comme ça puis le à 40 ans tu
pourrais vivre sur tes placements vous
restez toujours exact exact très bon
livre qui a été écrit par Jean-Sébastien
pilote qui s'apprête justement la
retraite à 40 ans il est publié deux ans
peut-être je l'avais interviewé pour
pour la presse puis Jean-Sébastien et ça
ça conjointe depuis vraiment ça qui ont
fait ils ont travaillé de l'âge de 23 24
ans à un petit peu avant 40 ans ils ont
mis de côté je pense à la fin c'était
quelque chose comme 60% 70% de leurs
revenus lui est en marketing
ils n'ont pas fait des immenses salaires
tant que ça mais justement en vivant sur
un des deux salaires eux ils ont voyagé
aussi beaucoup à travers ça puis
aujourd'hui ça retraite donc il voyage
ils sont super bons avec les cartes de
crédit les points c'est bon moi j'ai
jamais vraiment plongé là-dedans mais si
tu peux avoir la carte puis si tu
dépenses temps à trois mois
ça demande un peu d'organisation mais
bref eux ces voyages pour des équivalent
de 5000 pièces de de de billets d'avion
qui ont à cause des points mais mais oui
puis je suis considérais aux gens si les
gens lisent l'anglais d'aller lire le
blog de Mr money moustache sur sur
Internet qui est un des bugs et plus
populaires de la finance personnelle
c'est écrit par Peter adney qui est un
ontarien qui est allé faire carrière en
informatique au Colorado il y a 20-25
ans et lui il a pris sa retraite
23 24 puis 31 avec sa femme des deux ont
vraiment comme eux
maisons qui ont retapé eux-mêmes ils se
déplaçant en vélo
je veux pas dépenser une pièce et c'est
juste parce qu'il trouvait que c'était
plus le fun d'aller travailler donc
juste en faisant ça mais puis là au
niveau des restos encore là c'est ah tu
te prives ouais mais ok une gang de 4
qui va super resto une soirée pour se
voir puis jaser mais ça va peut-être
coûter 150 pièces par personne ou à
lever mais la même groupe de 4 qui qui
fait une maison ou dans un parc qui joue
à pétanque où elle veut
coûter 25 pièces par personne tu vois
les mêmes personnes tu as les mêmes
conversations il y a une différence de
400 %
donc l'idée dans le fond c'est pas de se
dire chez nous puis je mange
c'est vraiment de penser un peu
d'orienter faire des choix c'est dire ok
là ou bien avoir une mission à parler
des vélos quelqu'un qui a dort les vélos
qui adore faire du vélo ok c'est parfait
mais si ça te prend le vélo de l'année
puis ça prend l'auto de l'année puis ça
prend le resto donc tout le monde parle
ça c'est là que c'est là que toute ta
marge de manœuvre a disparaître mais si
toi tu dis moi j'adore les vélos puis
c'est mon Habib si les vélos
objectivement c'est pas bien de mon
pente à payer tu as pas dit c'est tu
vois en faire tu vas en faire le sport
extrêmement cher donc c'est il y a moyen
c'est de d'avoir de pas se priver le
fameux se privé tu sais
le cerveau
du moins je vois généraliser à part
tendre mon ma propre expérience mais on
dirait que
moi je suis quand même circuité dans mon
cerveau où est-ce que je vois de
l'argent dans mon compte puis on dirait
que dans mon subconscient c'est comme je
peux m'acheter ça mais je peux
m'acheter un vélo genre tu sais comme là
je comme on parlait je fais pas
longtemps je fais du vélo je me suis
comme Guérin en vélo parce que
j'ai du los budgétaire enfin que je vais
le mettre là soudainement le budgétaire
il est quand même disparu là ok j'en ai
plus dans le fond puis j'essaie de
réfléchir encore une fois en écoutant
des des podcasts sur ça je me suis dit
bon il était il est parti où mon loss
dans le fond parce que là je fais deux
fois le salaire que j'ai déjà fait dans
ma vie puis je peux plus libérer
financièrement c'est pourtant j'ai pas
l'impression que mon style de vie a
changé tu sais j'ai l'impression que je
vis sensiblement la même façon que je
vivais à l'université puis je fais je
fais beaucoup plus argent que je faisais
à l'université beaucoup plus à
l'université parce que j'en faisais
pratiquement pas puis j'ai l'impression
de vivre la même façon puis j'ai pas
plus de luxe qui me faut qu'il faut
quand même que faudrait en fait je pense
que l'exercice ce serait de toute mettre
sur papier de forcer c'est où que ça
s'en va dans le fond j'imagine faut que
tu fasses ça oui tu peux faire ça puis
il y a des applications les gens qui
dépensent disons tout sur la carte de
crédit pour tu pourras avoir les points
tu peux avoir une application qui
s'appelle Mint.com qui eux ils vont
analyser ta carte de crédit puis ils
vont dire que tu as dépenser tant en
épicerie tant au resto tout ça ça
encourage les gens à faire ça pour avoir
une vision parce que les gens font ça
des fois un resto tu sais ça va vite
mais oui c'est ça quand tu vois qui vois
l'argent nous a dépensé un restaurant en
restant cette année tu vas faire
exactement
50% cet argent là tu allais dans un
placement ça aurait été énorme sur mon
énorme bitsubis aux gens encore de
parler au resto je dis juste garde
choisi tes batailles tu sais puis tu
gardes-toi tu as des choses congelées
dans ton congélateur si tu sais que
quand ton frigo est vide c'est toujours
à partir aller au resto mais
généralement dans mon expérience c'est
pas les meilleurs restos c'est juste
parce qu'il va pas se faire tu es mieux
peut-être de couper cela puis de garder
sur qui sont vraiment spéciaux puis bon
mais c'est intéressant pour que tu
soulève de dire j'ai de l'argent je le
dépense puis j'arrive au même point
et je te disais que tu as parfaitement
raison c'est très très humain puis la
façon de court-circuiter ça si tu veux
c'est de faire des virements
automatiques c'est ça le jour de la paie
c'est ça la personne qui est capable de
faire ça ça c'est des études qui le
prouvent pas l'argent tu l'as pas tu
l'as jamais vu dans le fond quand tu es
salarié l'impôt est-ce que généralement
les gens revenus à la source en même pas
compte ok bon imagine que au lieu de
l'impôt mais c'est qui va au
gouvernement c'est l'argent qui va pour
trancher tu fais le même principe de
déduction à la source mais tu le vois
pas donc la personne justement pour
revenir à l'exemple du paiement de taux
de 450 mais jour de 450 avant la
déplacement bang tu l'as même pas vu
donc si tu es capable de faire ça là il
y a des applications que les gens
peuvent aller voir comme par exemple
word sympa qui est une application
canadienne qui est une compagnie
financière qui appartient à Power
Corporation parce que c'est une grosse
affaire sérieuse c'est pas juste une
petite apte sur le téléphone mais eux
elles font ce qui permettent ce qui
t'offre c'est de bâtir un portefeuille
de FNB qui est déjà tout fait selon tes
critères par exemple ton horizon c'est
quelqu'un qui est jeune moi j'ai pas
besoin cet argent super longtemps mais
eux ils vont mettre plus d'action un peu
moins d'obligation et eux vont te
permettre de faire un lien entre ton
compte chèque puis déplacement donc là
moi je l'ai fait j'ai fait un moins
sympa pour mon garçon on met 20 pièces
par mois qui part mais c'est à mon nom
parce que faut avoir 18 ans pour avoir
un compte mais bref l'argent s'accumule
mais donc la personne peut mettre quand
moi je mets 450 par pays dans Word tempo
puis l'argent disparaît puis là comme ça
tu viens vraiment de t'enlever aussi la
douleur tire au sens large de de
l'épingle de le voir de le voir partir
puis aussi de le faire c'est
de dire ah oui non j'ai oublié ce
mois-ci j'ai toujours cette attente la
fin du mois c'est il y en aura plus ça
c'est vraiment normal
exact donc c'est si tu le fais puis tu
le mets ce pilote automatique depuis
besoin d'y penser comme un peu un régime
de retraite quelqu'un qui est salarié se
rajoute de retraite les gens pensent pas
vraiment ça parce que ça se fait tout
seul c'est donc plus l'humain est
capable de mettre des décisions comme ça
sur le pilote automatique mais tu mets
les chances de ton de ton côté
quelqu'un qui nous écoute qui qui sait
parce que là tu parles de mètres 400
pièces par pays de côté on s'entend que
[Musique]
l'augmentation de salaire parce que de
toute façon c'est de l'argent que tu
avais pas précédemment puis que tu
vivais sans cet argent là donc cet
argent-là peut aller justement grossir
tes placements
mais j'avais quelques clic une personne
qui met 15 pièces par jour c'est
peut-être beaucoup pour une personne qui
qui commence là mais donc c'est
l'équivalent d'un lunch le midi ou
restaurant cette personne là dans le
marché c'est jouable
quand tu réfléchis à tes journées tes
dépenses juste penser à tes journées
depuis que j'ai acheté un chez Costco
une grosse affaire de café instantané le
mode je sais pas pourquoi j'aime ça le
café instantané c'est comme lié à un
souvenir en cas d'entraînement c'est ce
qu'on mange qu'on buvait puis genre ça
me ramène en Martinique
le maintenant que je mets c'est ça mon
café le matin ça c'était sympa
c'est 5 pièces de base le quand je
marchais puis je prenais un café ça
c'était 5 pièces c'est Saint-Pierre
grosse
le matin juste là c'est Saint-Pierre par
jour quand tu penses c'est quand même
jouable exactement
c'est presque 5000 pièces par année 5000
pièces par année vous dit si je disais
j'ai un article les gens peuvent aller
goler que ça s'appelle comment épargner
10000 dollars en 1 an puis là-dedans je
descends des des idées comme par exemple
moi mon cellulaire me coûte 11 pièces
par mois taxes inclus comment tu fais ça
à l'infini
moi je coupais là-dedans c'est pas ça
vient pas me chercher ça vient pas me
changer ma vie ça vient pas donc c'est
le père juste une encore ça c'est le
pire c'est que c'est tellement stupide
que je veux dire là mais je m'arrange je
m'en rends compte là j'étais sur mon
iPhone au chalet de ma mère ok en train
de d'être sur le 5G puis en train de
magasiner le tenez vous bien
des cellulaires sans application
puissant internet
c'est tellement toxique bon celle-là
mais j'étais en train de l'utiliser là
pour acheter un sel qui coûte 200 pièces
où est-ce que tu as pas d'application
puis pas d'internet juste pour être un
cellulaire genre
de vouloir acheter quelque chose pour me
débarrasser de mon seul en sachant très
bien que j'en ai que je m'en
débarrasserai pas là
je l'ai pas acheté
ton seul Atlas
moi je préfère de pub mais c'est avec
Public Mobile une petite compagnie mais
il y en a d'autres là moi j'ai pris le
forfait le plus de base qui est 15
pièces là par mois puis je pense quand
tu es là avec plusieurs années il baisse
un petit peu pour la fidélité tout ça
mais bref j'ai vraiment pas beaucoup de
données c'est juste assez pour faire
Google Maps puis les courriels
la plupart du temps mais bref juste pour
donner un exemple de choses moi j'ai des
voix les gens moi ça me coûte 80 pièces
par mois 75 pièces par mois mon dieu
c'est déjà là moi j'ai j'ai
60 pièces c'est ou même des fois c'est
avec le câble à la maison c'est mes
voisins me disaient récemment deux
cellulaires plus le câble ça leur coûte
en haut 200 pièces par mois ça deux
cellulaires plus le câble ça devrait
être en mode sans pièce dans dans mon
livre à moi là
[Musique]
mais c'est ça donc littéralement dans
ton lit en plus oui
mais donc en cherchant un peu donc les
gens s'attaque là c'est ça je l'ai fait
un peu justement pour montrer par
exemple si c'est la bibliothèque c'est
les gens ils pensent pas leur
bibliothèque locale mais il paye pas
mais le contraire de la bibliothèque tu
as
des lits bien sûr mais tu as des taxés
par exemple avec la Grande Bibliothèque
tu as accès à des livres électroniques
que tu peux aller sur une tablette ou
même ton téléphone tu as accès à des
audio des livres audio tu as accès même
à des magasins avec la Grande
Bibliothèque si tu peux lire des
économistes tu peux lire une New Yorker
tu peux lire à toutes les semaines c'est
là ça coûte des centaines de dollars par
année donc il y a vraiment les gens il y
a même des jeux de société que ça avec
mon garçon on va à bibliothèque on part
avec 30-40 livres là c'est fou c'est
pire on économise de cette façon là sur
Amazon ou sur d'autres dép mais donc
c'est ça les gens pensent pas ces
choses-là mais c'est là que tu peux
aller chercher un peu de marge de
manœuvre finalement par rapport à ta vie
que tu disais moi je suis mur à mesure
j'ai vraiment pas une scène où par
exemple les vêtements c'est
faire une petite parenthèse j'ai mon
j'ai monté sur gris mais en une douzaine
chez nous
identique pareil moi j'ai cinq t-shirts
exactement comme lui j'ai commandé 5
fois c'était chutes là j'ai fait il
marche bien je vois le prendre ça c'est
comme la technique de l'uniforme un peu
petite le matin tu mets quelque chose
toujours la même chose j'ai fait le test
au journal il y a peut-être trois quatre
ans je fais un test je me suis je me
suis mis à m'habiller pareil à tous les
jours et une autre journaliste fille a
fait la même chose avec le teasing gris
puis à la fin du mois tu allais voir nos
patrons on a dit Hey ça fait un mois je
t'avais pareil tu as marqué dans les
deux cas ils nous ont dit non ah ouais
ouais donc on est pas différent c'est
homme femme
du gris là mettez un espèce de foulard
de couleur tu sais qui a changé
non c'est pas c'est un besoin qu'on se
crée dans notre tête les gens les gens
sont pas là à nous scruter le temps que
ça là donc c'était un petit paquet qui
arrive là par la poste une nouvelle
blouse pour l'été machin ok c'est ça ça
s'accumule justement au bout de l'année
puis est-ce que ça te crée du bonheur
tant que ça c'est que dans tout quand tu
parlais tu dis mon salaire a doublé mais
tu sais je tourne même niveau que ça ça
s'appelle l'adaptation est donnée donc
dans le fond c'est comme sur un tapis
roulant puis tu as besoin d'aller
toujours un peu plus vite donc quand on
achète quelque chose ça nous donne un
petit buzz pendant si par exemple ton
téléphone mettons il est vieux où il est
lent il bug là pendant un mois tu vas
checker les téléphones en ligne tu vas
l'acheter tu vas le recevoir là pendant
un mois c'est comme une Ferrari il va
tellement vite c'est fou c'est pourquoi
j'ai pas fait ça avant mais au bout d'un
mois c'est juste ton téléphone le buzz
il est revenu ça c'est le même avec un
peu tout ce qu'on peut acheter dans la
vie de l'autre déjà un mois après tu
penses ah ouais faudrait mettre un
changement là peut-être là tu changes
ton laptop tu as la même phénomène et ça
tu peux tu peux tu peux être
millionnaire puis avoir puis le même
phénomène aussi c'est un resto faut que
je sais il faut que j'essaye tu l'asses
c'est cool un mois après c'est comme tu
étais jamais allé ça c'est vraiment le
cerveau humain qui est fait comme ça il
faut pas il faut le comprendre parce que
on va toujours chercher à aller chercher
plus d'expérience plus de luxe
c'est là que dans le fond qu'on va tout
dépenser nos notre pouvoir nos dollars
on les donne aux autres si on les donne
aux propriétaires de base on les donne
aux concessionnaire on les donne à belle
on les donne à Vidéotron on les donne à
tout le monde bon les gars pas pour nous
donc ça c'est un peu le principe de base
puis
dans mon expérience les gens sont
capables de d'aller couper des choses à
gauche à droite si je dis pas la main
monoparentale que trois enfants puis je
vais pas être le Nono qui qui est
sensible à ça je parle pour des gentil
des gens qui sont seuls ou qui sont en
couple c'est par exemple prends un
couple de prof du secondaire
qui donne là
prévisible et tout il donne l'heure
en fait prend un couple de prof de
l'université puis donne-leur le train de
vie d'un propre d'un couple de propre du
secondaire si on vient de dire que les
profs secondaires ils ont bien mais le
prof d'université qui gagne pas moins
450000 pièces de plus chaque
puis mettre de côté dans 15 ans c'est
fini là puis c'est des gens qui ont
voyagé des gens qui sont allés au resto
des gens qui sont c'est juste que quand
tu es dans une autre braquette tu as
l'impression que ton auto doit changer
tu as l'impression que là où tu vas en
vacances doit changer
le genre de rénovation que tu as ou pas
chez vous doit changer tout ça c'est des
choix c'est il y a personne qui nous met
un fusil s'attendre qui dit qu'il faut
que tu dépenses chaque pièce que tu
gagnes peu importe ton salaire ça c'est
c'est créé par un peu l'air du temps
mais ce sera le fun si je serai le
premier à dire à chaque fois des
vêtements de marque ça va te rendre
heureux
c'est ça la solution c'est c'est malade
ou double ta grandeur de maison là tu
vas capoter ça va être seul la solution
mais non on le sait c'est Jim Carrey qui
a dit j'aimerais ça que tout le monde
soit riche et célèbre une fois dans leur
vie pour qu'il se rend compte que c'est
pas ça la solution
ça c'est
forte à des niveaux comme Jim Carrey
pour Laurent le réaliser c'est si tu
t'engueule avec ton champ du tableau
dans un
appartener
c'est c'est pas ça qui va c'est qui qui
va changer ta vie tant que ça c'est pour
pour la bémol par rapport à Paul la
bémol mais juste une
parenthèse intéressante par rapport à
tes mettons la voiture de l'année ou la
nouvelle pièce de designer de l'année
moi il y a des affaires que avant
j'étais cheap sur l'achat maintenant je
vais prendre l'exemple de lunettes pour
le sport lunettes soleil pour le sport
là une compagnie qui s'appelle gooder
qui font des lunettes qui initialement
était comme 25 pièces se sont rendus à
35 pièces mais c'est genre vraiment ces
lunettes de qualité
ich le tu sais où est-ce que tu achètes
puis que tu as pas l'impression de
dépenser pour des hauts clips à faire
même sauf que tes mails a amené ce
graphique l'amener ils sont hyper de la
qualité et puis le dernier tu vois moins
bien et puis là
j'ai acheté dernièrement une paire de
notes parce que j'ai vraiment mis
beaucoup d'argent sur une part de
lunettes de sport mais à chaque fois que
je les mets je suis content chaque fois
je les mets c'est genre
j'ai choisi ma voiture que j'ai
maintenant que le monde savent sont au
courant qu'on vient je paye par mois
pour ma voiture mais qui était quand
même haut de gamme pour ce que je serais
capable de payer à ce moment-là si
c'était à ma limite supérieure mais
jusqu'à maintenant ça fait quatre ans
que je lis chaque fois que je rentre
dedans c'est comme tout le temps content
de rentrer dans ma voiture tu sais bah
oui il y a de quoi là-dedans aussi était
de dire de dépenser sur l'affaire que tu
sais qui va te rendre heureux quand tu
vas l'utiliser ou le mettre mettons le
tuer exact mais oui comme moi aussi j'ai
des lunettes de soleil qui m'ont coûté
cher mais j'ai ça dans face six mois par
année moi ça me dérange pas de dépenser
plus pour la qualité pour des choses que
j'utilise c'est ça sur une régulière moi
là où j'ai depuis misère c'est que ah si
je fais telle affaire trois fois par
année c'est à dire que 362 jours par
année c'est dans le garde-robe c'est ce
qui de randonnée sont en garde-robe
comme ça ils regardent c'est puis
pendant que je suis sur zone tu sais
j'ai un peu moins euh ouais c'est mais
oui la qualité c'est par exemple une
belle voiture des gens qui aiment moi
j'ai toujours mais les voitures dans ma
vie c'était les voitures de qualité
quand même qui était qui était belle et
qui était pas si bien que ça mais
justement si tu vas vers une voiture un
petit peu usagée tu sais que c'est 30-40
km tu as le buzz de la voiture
ça sent le champ neuf bon mais là tu
sauves la dépréciation tu vas sauver un
25-35 souvent donc là la personne peut
aller vers une voiture disant en 2018
puisqu'on est en 2023 quelque chose
comme ça mais là cette voiture là encore
un autre il prend soin de ça donc il y a
moyen type de pas ou c'est comme un peu
la personne qui aime fabriquer des
meubles ou br
[Musique]
qui revient comme ça tu t'en vas pas
vraiment compte où les abonnements sur
Internet
les forfaits qui coûtent trop cher
l'épicerie c'est des fois tu vois les
gens qui ont qui sont très très serrés
mais si ils ont ils vont dans les
épiceries c'est super cher
exactement avril et tout le savon c'est
c'est du savon c'est quasiment fait par
des moines tibétains
mais encourager les fermes bio mais ça
coûte vraiment cher exactif avec moi je
serai plus tendance à dire c'est penser
comme vraiment ce qui vous donne du
plaisir si c'est ton fan d'aller vers
ces produits là mais fais-le
consciemment mais fais pas comme les 50
autres choses à côté aussi
devant télé parce que c'est
sauvage mais oui
j'en connais plein du monde que c'est
comme à ton peu de cuis
presque chaque jour là
c'est déjà cher 17 pièces il coûte 32
même temps ouais
c'est aussi d'apprendre des skills de
base de de cuisine de savoir quoi
acheter des savons comment justement à
l'épicerie comment d'être moi j'étais un
maniaque de checker les coups par 100 g
et aussi
capable je suis comme ça ah non ça c'est
trois points 2 par 100 g on peut pas
acheter ça mais ça c'est 0.9
le truc que tu avais l'impression qui
était cher parce que parce que le prix
était quelque chose le truc
du riz à l'infini c'est pour 12 pièces
c'est vraiment plus économique que ton
petit fromage alumi genre à 12 pièces
mais que tu as deux bouchées avec ça
c'est comme ça permet vraiment de
demander de remettre les prix à aller
d'un fruiterie aussi moi j'ai commencé à
faire ça maintenant je vois
l'infruiterie à place d'aller à
l'épicerie de panier mes affaires à
l'épicerie normale une caisse de fruits
et légumes ça revient tellement pas cher
genre c'est fou les choses en saison
puis oui c'est toujours avoir si tu le
sais que toi tu es déjà quand ton frigo
est vide ben tes gens à commander du
pari mais ça arrange toi pour avoir des
choses congelées je sais pas les sachet
de pesto là des fois sont en vente par
exemple
3 location en vente c'est ça c'est 25 là
c'est comme si tu mélanges ton lit il
faut le métier tu vas voir quelque chose
puis c'est pas toujours avoir un plan B
que de faire venir de cette barre ou
quoi que ce soit puis c'est fait le va
au resto quand c'est quand un soirée
quand c'est le fun quand c'est la fête
de quelqu'un quoi que ce soit oui mais
ça aussi ça revient je trouve que c'est
bon moi j'ai 46 ans quand j'étais dans
la vingtaine je trouve qu'il y avait
moins d'occasions de dépenser parce que
l'économie puis les commerces
s'adressaient pas à moi c'est les restos
il s'en foutaient de moi quand j'avais
20 ans il y avait pas c'est Instagram ou
toutes les côtés un peu genre reviens
puis c'est les super belles assiettes et
tout l'expérience tout ça c'était comme
les restos il parlant à mes parents ils
parlent pas à moi mais je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui dès qu'on arrive les gens
même pas 20 ans ils ont déjà des goûts
tu sais moi j'ai ce goût là puis j'aime
la pinocrisio c'est quand même moi j'ai
au secondaire si on buvait du vin
c'était du vin d'épicerie qu'on a
quelqu'un dans le parti
juste content de l'avoir c'est ça mais
là tu deviens
foudy à 19 ans là c'est comme Pierre
mixword une phrase que j'ai c'est que je
me souviens c'est plus le compte
Instagram est beau à 30 ans c'est plus
tant pis la marge de manœuvre c'est
c'est comme c'est directement
proportionnel tu sais puis c'est les
meilleurs que j'ai interview pour mon
livre un dollar truc en guillemets c'est
qu'ils ont tout fait les choses que les
que le monde fait en général sauf
quelques années plus tard par exemple
oui ils vont oui ils vont au Club Med
mais ils sont allés pour la première
fois peut-être à 37 38 ans quand il y
avait des enfants ils sont parlé à 27
ans ou que le même type à 27 ans il
était en PACS en Europe ou des voyages
pas chers donc c'est dans le fond il
repousse un peu toutes les le train de
vie qu'on s'accapare on dirait la
seconde qu'on peut maintenant puis donc
en faisant repoussant un peu le moment
où tu fais ça soit le faire dans ta vie
la vie c'est quand même assez long là je
vous le confirme que tu as des enfants
tu es prêt à télécharger
c'est
ces expériences-là ils vont venir tu vas
l'apprécier autant sinon plus un peu
plus tard puis c'est la personne qui a
ses 22 ans la personne qui a 55 ans qui
sont au même restaurant qui mange le
même repas il paye deux prix différents
parce que la personne devait de 55 ans
peut-être que son rapport qui coûte je
sais pas moi 75 pièces peut-être ça y
est écouté 12 pièces parce que c'est de
l'argent qui est fructifier dans le
temps mais la personne elle à côté elle
paie le vrai 75 puis dans le fond à paye
bien plus parce que
c'est 75 ans va peut-être prendre 500
pièces car ces personnes-là va avoir 55
ans donc c'est tout un peu de voir les
choses comme ça c'est sur le long même
chose pour une auto une voiture de
l'année un Jeep machin chouette ok paye
toi le plus tard dans la vie quand tu
seras rendu là puis il va te coûter des
peanuts comparé à l'argent que imagine
voir tout imagine être à 20 ans puis
avoir la
maturité et la lucidité d'esprit de voir
toutes les dépenses comme ce qui
signifie
dans 30 ans ça coûterait 5 fois que tu
achètes quelque chose ça coûterait cinq
fois plus cher que de ne pas l'acheter
mais ça une fois que tu vois les choses
comme ça tu peux plus revenir en arrière
tu fais ah ouais ok donc là tu vas faire
des meilleurs choix parce que tu
comprends le pouvoir de l'argent ça
revient ce que dit l'argent c'est pas
juste des points que tu changes comme
des objets c'est c'est c'est des
travailleurs qui peuvent travailler pour
toi toute ta vie puis tu peux avoir tu
peux être propriétaire de chaque petit
compagnie tu sais que par exemple une
des actions que j'ai dans mon dans mes
fonds indiciel c'est burger ataway qui
l'accompagnait de Warren Buffett puis
BIRT à oui possède Dairy Queen bon c'est
Nono il passait de le coup mais quand il
y a une file au Dairy Queen par une chez
nous mon garçon qui a 10 ans qui était
papa c'est bon ça je dis oui c'est bon
parce que nous on possède une petite
partie de Dairy Queen ok donc là tu
commences à voir la société comme ça tu
commences à avoir les entreprises c'est
la personne qui s'achète un nouveau
iPhone tout est content parce que tu
possèdes un petit peu d'Apple donc quand
tu vois les choses comme ça tu changes
un peu ta perspective tu sais puis tu
sais un peu ce que ça peut faire pour
toi dans le fond mais par rapport au thé
par rapport à la valeur de l'argent
justement le type de ce qui vaut ton
resto à 20 ans versus à 50 ans si on
parle depuis le début de conversation un
peu avec le présupposé que les gens
comprennent
l'aspect exponentiel de l'investissement
mais je pense ça peut être intéressant
quand même de l'expliquer comme à quel
petit comment ça fonctionne puis
pourquoi c'est juste pourquoi mettons
pendant 40 ans si tu mets de mes pièces
de côté c'est pas 40000 pièces à la fin
c'est c'est des fois plusieurs fois
plusieurs fois ça puis le pourquoi en
fait de comment ça fonctionne exactement
l'aspect exponentiel le cerveau humain
pas fait pour comprendre
l'exponentielle on peut compter les
choses mais on peut pas voir qu'elle se
multiplie donc l'argent se multiplie
enfin un exemple très simple
imagine que les parents à la naissance
de leur enfant
donne mettre un dollar par jour de la
vie de l'enfant dans le marché boursier
canadien OK puis à 20 ans l'enfant prend
le relais puis mais le même dollar
jusqu'à 65 ans mais cette personne là
avec juste une pièce par jour tout le
long va arriver à 65 ans avec un point 6
millions
qui est personne qui s'est privé
là-dedans puis mettons c'est ce qu'il en
mettant 65 fois 365 pièces c'est pas
tant de pièces que ça pour arriver à 1.6
millions exact mais l'enfant numéro 2
les disons l'enfant numéro 2 les parents
ont pas mis cette pièce là par jour dans
son enfance mais cet enfant-là a
commencé à mettre sa pièce par jour à
l'âge de 20 ans cette personne-là sera
en 65 ans combien elle a emplacement 200
c'est une différence de 1.4 millions ok
c'est ça la croissance exponentielle
c'est ça c'est pour ça que le temps
comme je parlais tantôt c'est vraiment
la clé de la multiplication des
placements c'est que sur une courte
période puis j’écris un article aussi
quelques mois les gens pour aller voir
ça s'appelle pourquoi le premier 100000
et le plus difficile à accumuler
parce que ça parle je crois que ça fasse
pas vraiment 5000 là comme un moyen gros
chiffre mais dans votre vie si vous
travaillez toute votre vie vous allez
arriver à des chiffres comme ça et le
100 000 le premier est difficile à
cumuler parce que c'est toute la sueur
de ton front ok parce que le marché
travaille pas vraiment beaucoup pour toi
parce que imagine la personne qui a dit
mes pièces en placement puis là le
marché fait mettons 10 % une année en
quitterrandit à 11000 ou c'est une
personne est content excitée de ça c'est
pas ok donc dans le fond cette personne
là cette année-là elle peut mettre 6000
de côté
elle va avoir eu une augmentation de 60%
c'est d'avoir eu vraiment un retour
incroyable alors que le marché est pas
vraiment un facteur dans son
enrichissement mais avant jusqu'à la
personne qui a 100 000 qui est un peu
plus vieille et tout mais cette personne
là si le marché fait 10 % une année
l'autre est à 110 puis imagine la
personne elle a mis cette année-là 10000
pièces de côté est à 120 donc là en une
année elle vient de prendre 20 000 ok
mais le marché un peu plus bouger
qu'avant la personne qui a un million
puis le marché fait 10 %, mais de
s'enrichir de 100000 à pas travailler
plus fort cette année-là c'est pas levé
à 3 heures avant pour méditer puis faire
un journal de gratitude puis faire les
affaires qu'on entend qui
à la fois plus travailler fort ça que
une des leçons c'est que je parlais au
millionnaire qui me racontait ils m'ont
dit j'ai fait ça sans effort il y a le
côté de l'effort puis c'est dur de se
défaire de cette idée là on a
l'impression que tu peux t'enrichir il
faut très fort et tout je suis pas
contre le travail c'est juste que écoute
si travailler fort ça amenait un
enrichissement les gens qui travaillent
les plus fort la société souvent c'est
pas les gens qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent c'est donc c'est pas il faut un
peu dissocier ça c'est une fois que ton
argent travaille pour toi comme je
parlais du 100000 mais là c'est c'est
presque une machine à faire de l'argent
donc donc donc faut pas se décourager au
début les gens justement moi les gens
m'écrivent voir là j'ai 22 ans j'ai les
chiffres bougent pas beaucoup dans mes
placements tu sais faire c'est tu as
même pas à regarder ça
dans 30 ans
puis justement là dessus une étude
intéressante qui a été faite exoné aux
États-Unis par la compagnie fidélité qui
est une compagnie de gestion d'actifs
ils ont des millions de clients et on
fait une analyse allaitante ça c'est des
anciens employés qui qui ont dit ça dans
des dans des podcasts et tout mais il
est analysé parmi les millions de
clients d'investisseurs lesquels avaient
le meilleur rendement puis se rendre
compte que
professionnels à l'intelligent qui font
qui vont gérer ton argent pour toi
excessivement peu qui battent ça très
très rare et puis en plus tu leur donnes
une côte en plus leur donne un deux pour
cent souvent au Canada on paye on est
très généreux on paye les frais qui sont
parmi les plus élevés au monde pour
faire gérer notre argent à notre place
donc les personnes qui le font eux-mêmes
puis le bon c'est sûr que c'est un autre
sujet là dans le sens où les gens qui
font la gestion de portefeuille ils vont
dire oui mais l'investisseur moyen est
tellement cabochon que il va il va faire
pleinierie puis il va perdre plus que
moi ce que ce qui me paye en frais c'est
vrai je posais le contrat mais si si
justement tu essaies de jouer à essayer
de deviner quelle entreprise va blow-up
ou investir mais si tu dis juste je me
tiens dans un fond le SNP 500 justement
j'y touche plus avant c'est la meilleure
chose que je peux faire exact c'est pas
que je dis que elle s'investir sa
richesse une question de comportement
bien plus qu'une question de revenu puis
de ça puis aussi ça fait penser à un
point c'est que souvent on va lire dans
les journaux ah il y a une relation qui
là on va dire c'est pas le temps
d'acheter parce que je vais acheter dans
six mois quand les quand ça va être en
vente ok donc toute cette game là elle
est constante et encore une fois c'est
très contre intuitif mais c'est vraiment
n'importe quoi tu peux jamais savoir où
le marché va être dans six mois dans un
an dans deux ans c'est trop imprévisible
pour pour la recherche que je faisais
récemment pour un article je suis en
train d'écrire l'automne dernier souvent
tu vas lire dans le journal ou quoi que
ce soit les experts des marchés vont
dire ah c'est pas le temps d'acheter ou
faut être défensif et tout
99,99%
l'automne dernier
le gros message c'était soyez bien bébé
prudent et conservateur garder beaucoup
d'argent cash et n'achetez surtout pas
d'entreprise de technologie là presque
un an plus tard le secteur qui a le
mieux performé depuis un an technologie
ok donc 40%, je pense c'est jamais vu
donc c'est le commencé à regarder
prenez des notes quand les gens vont
faire des pronostics comme ça c'est la
récession ou ballon l'inflation va
monter va baisser prenez des notes c'est
suivi suivez un peu ça là c'est
n'importe quoi les gens les experts
n'ont pas la science infuse on de la
misère à dire ce qui va bien faire dans
un an dans deux ans
les taux d'intérêts la hausse c'était
absolument pas prévu
et donc c'est ça donc l'investisseur se
nuit
en faisant un peu du Gumball avec ah
telle compagnie va faire bien sûr je
vais aller voir ça mais l'investisseur
se nuit aussi en vendant quand c'est
haut dans sa tête puis en voulant
racheter quand c'est bas il y a tout un
espèce de Game de dire ça puis moi j'ai
beaucoup d'amis qui ont fait ça au début
de la pandémie quand ça coûte le début
de la pandémie là tu regardais les
marchés ça tombait de 8 9 % avant
l'heure du lunch là c'était comme à
chaque jour mon ami les gens là et
regarde ça ils font ok moi je sors de ça
puis je remarquerai plus tard c'est
humain de vouloir faire ça c'est humain
de vouloir c'est comme si des gens c'est
débarquent comment ça te casser les
jambes est-ce que tu vas te laisser
faire mais non tu vas utiliser chaque
pipe de ton aide pour te dire mais en
investissement c'est l'inverse déjà
arrive puis tape dessus il faut que tu
te laisses faire c'est c'est vraiment
parfait
mais c'est pour ça que on est les
humains on est on est pratiquement
c'est comme la pire programmation notre
cerveau pour investir faut faire le
contraire de ce que nous savons nous dit
que notre got feeling nous dit moi quand
j'ai commencé à investir plus
sérieusement c'était en 2012 après mon
erreur
2012 puis à ce moment-là c'est j'étais
aux souvenirs à ce moment-là il est les
marchés ça allait pas bien le pistes
comme il y avait du chômage puis c'était
comme là j'ai acheté des actions je fais
là j'avais vraiment pas l'impression de
faire la guillemets la bonne chose je le
faisais parce que les livres que j'avais
lu me disaient de faire ça puis des gens
qui faisait confiance et tout mais mon
gode feeling si j'avais écouté j'aurais
jamais fait ça fait x 4 puis on parle de
on parle de récession ou quoi que ce
soit on va toujours parler de session on
va toujours parler de de oui mais ça va
pas bien en Asie oui mais oui mais il y
a toujours un oui mais avec avec
l'économie avec ces choses-là et la
personne qui est capable de passer par
de ça puis de voir pour se casser c'est
comme du bruit il va toujours avoir du
bruit mais c'était capable de juste
investir sur le pilote automatique
si tu vas tu vas battre tes 90% des gens
de ta courte de ton âge de ton niveau
d'éducation
puis malheureusement c'est tout ce qu'on
discute là tu sais c'est très très peu
enseigné à l'école c'est que au
secondaire et on ramener le code
d'économie mais c'est pas optimal c'est
pas qu'on parlait de ça
au final je veux dire
mettons je disais ton IUT avant de lire
que le bon ça va être quand même du de
la grosse théorie ça va être compliqué
puis toute puis le plus je lisais le
livre puis tu sais où finalement à
manette tu comprends un peu le principe
puis justement finalement c'est simple
dans le sens que tu es c'est la chose la
plus simple c'est comment commence le
plus tôt possible mais en régulièrement
mais ça dans un dans un fond qu'une
croissance c'est qui finalement que on
se rend compte que ça bon n'importe quel
économiste n'importe quel banquier de
Wall Street
[Musique]
en fonction de ça ça prend quelques
secondes et la minute que tu transfères
l'argent dans ce compte-là il est déjà
placé ça commence pas de transaction à
faire tu as pas de dire ok j'achète mon
fond et il coûte 33 pièces j'ai 400
pièces combien d'unités j'en achète tout
ça c'est fait pour toi eux se paye en
prenant un petit frère annuel qui est
beaucoup moins bas que ce que
l'industrie prend en général c'est
stérile dans une banque un bonjour
monsieur juin investir eux ce qu'ils
vont faire c'est qu'on va mettre ton
argent dans les fonds comme un placement
il faut quand un placement c'est un
produit qui est très payant pour
l'institution financière mais
malheureusement qui a pas une très bonne
réputation à long terme parce que
justement c'est des gens qui c'est des
gestionnaires qui choisissent à la pièce
les compagnies qui sont là dedans puis
comme on l'explique depuis tantôt la
sélection de compagnie neuf fois sur 10
ça donne pas de bons résultats à long
terme donc
les fonds que les banques proposent
des investissements avec des jardins
maintenant
c'est pas des fonds qui ressemblent au
SNP 500 ou des genres de fonds comme ça
où ça dépend ce qu'ils vont faire ils
vont dire ok toi tu es plus croissance
aussi il y a des mots des besoins un peu
pour ce qui montre et dans le fonds
qui peut acheter justement dans Watson
qui élimine certaines compagnies là
mais bref oui eux ce qu'ils vont faire
c'est qu'ils vont ils vont faire un peu
ils vont filtrer les compagnies qui vont
choisir c'est un peu choisi par une
personne ok d'ailleurs ça puis plus tu
es retires les personnes de l'équation
mieux c'est puis tu vas payer en frais
si tu fais juste aller à la banque ou à
la caisse pizza soit payé à peu près 2%
en frais annuel ça c'est c'est vraiment
beaucoup parce que si l'inflation prend
trois puis toi puis la banque prend deux
ça fait 5 donc cet enfant a fait 5% de
rendement tu restes il reste il reste
pas d'argent non c'est ça donc puis là
parce que les gens aussi des fois vont
dire que moi quand j'ai commencé
investir la personne qui m'a rendu les
placements sur ce que je suis super
jeune je le compte j'attends dans mon
lit mais c'était pas des grosses sommes
mais j'ai dit moi là je veux rien perdre
je veux pas c'est de l'argent j'ai
travaillé cet argent là Noé que je vais
ouvrir mon compte puis je vais voir que
ça a baissait voyons donc si si je veux
pas faire ça là dépenser je vais en
avoir 10 fois avec j'avais vraiment pas
la même mentalité puis au lieu que au
lieu qu'il m'oriente vers ce qui
m'explique qui met du ben il m'a mis
dans un fond hyper conservateur mais
avec des rendements qui battaient même
pas l'inflation donc lui il y avait la
paix parce que moi je paniquais pas mais
je faisais à peu près pas de rendement
puis il prenait des gros frais on
rebrasse c'était pas un beau portrait
mais mais donc ça c'est pas pour
commencer je dirais les gens d'aller
vers Word sympa puis justement
d'investir dans un un Fortis si vous
êtes dans la 20 devriez avoir quelque
chose comme 80% action 20% obligations
avec
en sachant très bien que vous allez
avoir des chutes de 30% là c'est
peut-être pas de même matin mais
peut-être dans cinq ans dans 10 ans puis
ça c'est comme quand il y a une chute
les gens viennent me voir ça va tomber
comme elle est passée je pense à tomber
de 20 %
j'aime bien
c'est quoi ça marche plus c'est quoi je
mets non c'est comme c'est comme une
tempête de neige au mois de janvier je
dis on devrait pas être surpris de ça
mais c'est quand on commence c'est
surprenant puis ça ça fait mal c'est pas
que c'est quand même bien parce que
quand on est jeune les montants sont pas
gros donc on peut se familiariser avec
les marchés tu sais si les gens à 50 ans
ou 60 ans ils vendent leur compagnie
puis là ils se mettent à investir là ils
vont avoir une difficulté parce que ça
peut bouger de centaines de milliers de
dollars avec des gros montants mais
quand on est jeune on commence un autre
façon d'investir ça peut être aussi
d'ouvrir un compte de courtage
avec soit des jardins ou les banques
donc juste à gobelet et compte de
courtage puis le nom de votre banque
vous allez arriver sur le formulaire à
remplir tout ça c'est juste un fond
c'est une plateforme pour transiger à la
Bourse toutes les institutions
financières en eau puis là vous avez pas
d'accompagnement ou quoi que ce soit
mais vous pouvez aller acheter des fonds
négociants en bourse dans je parlais
tantôt juste à Google et ses fonds les
compagnies qui les vendent les plus
grosses au Canada c'est Van girl BMO et
Black Rock donc si vous allez voir un
peu les offres ok ben chaque fond un nom
comme celui chez Van girl c'est Vego VG
r o celui chez Black crocks c'est x gros
et X g r o donc si vous Google x gros V
gros vous allez voir le fond qui vous
est proposé
et dans le fond c'est juste de rentrer
c'est l'être là dans dans
la page qui vous permet de transiger de
acheter
vos actions au lieu d'acheter une action
d'une compagnie d'acheter un fond là
vous avez pas de frais qui est pris à
part le frais du FMB en question mais
sont réputées par des frais extrêmement
bas donc au lieu de payer 2 %, ça va
être payé point 2 pour ça donc là c'est
sur le long terme il y a une coupe de
Mercedes de Audi là dedans là qui va qui
va vous rester dans votre compte plutôt
calé dans le compte de la personne qui
vous vend les qui vend les fonds tu sais
parce que on dirait que de transiger
c'est quand même un genre de un sol tu
sais comment ça puis moi on dirait que
transigé par une application externe à
mon à ma banque on dirait que ça me fait
peur mais c'est sûr que c'est on dirait
que ça serait vraiment plus simple je
pouvais être sur accéder là puis jusqu'à
dire ok ça c'est un autre con qui est là
tu peux faire ça Desjardins ils ont leur
plateforme ça peut être Disnat puis là
on a le fond quand tu vas loger tu vas
la page de compte va avoir une ligne
déplacement dans le fond là ce qu'il
faut que tu fasses c'est juste que tu
achètes le FNB toi-même puis il y a
vraiment beaucoup de fournisseurs de FNB
avec des comme je disais des niveaux de
risque différents
et puis donc un rendement inspiré
différents aussi c'est plus c'est moins
c'est conservateurs moins faire
à long terme et puis c'est ça il y a des
gens qui peuvent être il y a des gens
des fois qui m'écrivent ok
tu parles du SNP 500 ça c'est dans le
fond c'est la Bourse américaine qui a
très très bien fait depuis
historiquement très bien fait mais
surtout depuis 10 ans et les gens me
disent mais pourquoi je mets pas toute
la dent là-bas et puis dans le fond
c'est que
ce que ce qui est plus intéressant avec
les fonds dont je pense c'est qu'une
diversification est internationale donc
c'est le fond vigro de Van girl grown
tant à peu près 12 ou 13000 compagnies
là-dedans donc dans à peu près 40 pays
donc finalement une décennie les les
États-Unis peuvent super bien faire
comme ça vient de se passer mais il est
pas dit que ça va être la même histoire
pour les 10 prochaines années donc c'est
quand tes diversifié dans ton
portefeuille il y a toujours des choses
qui vont moins bien faire des choses qui
vont mieux faire donc c'est un petit peu
ça l'idée que les gens faut qu'ils
pensent parce que les gens m'écrivent
500 c'est malade oui c'est malade mais
un ils viennent de faire la meilleure
décennie de l'histoire tu sais ça va
peut-être pas se répéter puis deux
tes tes
cours après ça s'appelle du performance
chasing tu cours après ce qui était hot
qui veut pas dire que ça va être hot
nécessairement demain matin encore c'est
donc ça ça fait partie un peu de des
choses à garder en tête mais oui tu peux
facilement avec ta main moi j'étais avec
ma banque aussi j'achète mes fonds moi
ça me prend investir là ça me prend mon
dieu c'est même prendre 20 minutes par
année des jours mes affaires au mois de
janvier je mets le réel le régime
épingle là-dessus de mon garçon
je mets ça au mois de janvier à chaque
mille fois je ferme ça on s'envoie dans
un an c'est c'est très très simple
j'explique dans mon livre justement un
peu comment
mécaniquement faire ça mais mais c'est
ça puis en plus petite blague pour mon
livre il est disponible à la
bibliothèque donc si les gens veulent ne
pas l'acheter regarde si je craque avec
ça vous pouvez le même informer
électronique moi j'ai le PDF je peux
vous l'envoyer
mais c'est ça donc
c'est c'est assez simple dans le fond
puis faut pas nécessaire là vraiment
d'une personne c'est passionné par ça
c'est
pour comprendre les la base puis le
mettre en place une fois que justement
que vous avez votre word tempo ou quoi
que ce soit une fois que c'est pilote
automatique vous avez juste à juste
vivre votre vie puis c'est pas pensé à
ça
parce que si on parle depuis tantôt de
long terme de super long terme tu sais
puis moi on dirait que tu dis ok le
temps tu mets dans l'autre boîte simple
qui existait pas vous le disant qui là
on sait même pas la technologie va être
ou dans 20 30 ans
on dirait que ça on dirait que c'est
comme anxiogène de faire ok je vais
mettre sur mon argent à travers de quoi
qui pourrait fermer
la presse avant puis ça c'est une grosse
team financière canadienne c'est ces
entreprises sont vraiment auditées
c'est pas comme investir en crypto que
justement il y a des applications qui
ont disparu plutôt juste perdu ton
argent ta clé sera disque dur qui est au
dépatoueur puis le fauteuil trouver en
2012 puis mais c'est ça c'est donc la
crypto ce sont pas vraiment parler mais
c'est ça si tu vas avoir du playmonie
puis faire ça ben c'est c'est correct
mais c'est juste que c'est ça la crypto
c'est plus quelque chose que si tu veux
t'amuser c'est comme du gamebling un peu
pour toi c'est quelque chose qui était
pour la fun mais c'est pas quelque chose
que tu fais pour avoir des des une
retraite assuré maintenant exact
peut-être il y en a qui vont sauter en
attendant ça puis je suis correct mais
et puis c'est la crypto très bien fait
récemment mais ça peut avoir là la même
chose pendant le fond c'est quoi la
bourse puis les placements c'est une
ligne de texte sur un écran mais dans la
mais dans la vraie vie c'est bien plus
que une ligne de chiffres de textes sur
un écran dans la vraie vie tu es
légalement propriétaire d'une entreprise
tu es copropriétaires d'une entreprise
c'est pas c'est pas des jokes tu peux
voter pour savoir ça va être qui le
directeur du conseil d'administration
c'est intéressant tu peux faire ça parce
que sinon tu mais moi je reçois dans La
Poste à chaque année veux-tu voter pour
te rafater il y a des protections des
investisseurs c'est des des
propriétaires d'entreprises ça donc
c'est c'est quelque chose qui si tu
passais des entreprises qui produit des
objets que les gens achètent ou des
services ou des ce que tu veux la crypto
c'est plus dans le fond tu vis tu tu
prends pour acquis que ça va augmenter
de valeur c'est sur le long terme c'est
un peu seul la game là puis tu vas être
tu vas être le plutôt possible dans la
game puis tout ça bon j'ai pas d'opinion
c'est pour ou contre autre que c'est
fait attention c'est pas c'est pas un
espèce de formule magique qui va
enrichir tout le monde
mais moi personnellement j'ai plus
tendance à y aller avec quelque chose
qui est plus sûr et qui est moins
conservateur à long terme juste des
entreprises qui existent les gens
achètent des produits apôt je pense
qu'ils vont encore dans la machine à 50
les services Microsoft il achète à faire
il fait juste augmenter donc c'est ça ça
c'est quelque chose qui est plus
tangible pour moi même si les gens ont
tendance à dire la bourse c'est pas
tangible mais dans la vraie vie les gens
dépensent puis cet enlève quelque part
c'est donc puis justement aussi toujours
choisir le prochain
le la prochaine super compagnie c'est
c'est là que c'est moi je décroche parce
que les 8 peux le faire une fois ou deux
peut-être pas peut-être planter
peut-être mais les fonds dans un sens
c'est quasiment trop facile quasiment la
triche dans un sens parce que les bonnes
compagnies rentrent dedans ceux qui
peuvent font moins ça fait ça
automatiquement
juste dans les compagnies qui
fonctionnent le mieux c'est une qui se
met à plus fonctionner et elle était
injectée par ce fond là c'est
autonettoyant donc une compagnie comme
Tesla peut rejoindre le ça c'est un vrai
exemple durant la pandémie un lait de
médecine a sorti du SNP 500 parce que
les ventes à diminuer et tout un casque
qualifier plus pour être dans les 500
plus grandes compagnies puis Tesla a
rejoint le SNP 500 parce que les ventes
augmentaient à être ça donc c'est un
fond qui est un peu autonettoyant
la Tesla
c'était le Millenial puis le boomer
[Musique]
juste avoir la moyenne ben ça te met
dans un petit groupe d'élite dans le
fond des gens qui ont un peu compris
comment fonctionne le système
puis je reviens aux côtés pratico
pratique de comment faire ça
sur ton
avec avec ta banque tu pourrais avoir le
plateforme de courtage pour acheter des
actions mais mettons les programmes
comme rayeur c'est lui tout seul qui est
gouvernementaux finalement qui qui est
pour avoir des manières de justement
d'avoir de l'argent à l'abri de l'impôt
pour la retraite tout seul tu peux tu
avoir ces
avantages-là mais en investissant dans
la bourse exactement donc quand tu vas
ouvrir ton compte avec de courtage avec
ta banque ou avec Desjardins les vont
dire ok quel genre de compte tu veux
ouvrir est-ce que tu veux ouvrir un
compte réel un compte Celli Célia
un compte non enregistré ça ça veut dire
non enregistré c'est juste des
placements choix qui sont pas à l'abri
de l'impôt dans un verre dans un cellier
c'est comme des bois puis ce que tu peux
mettre dans tu peux mettre plein de
choses dans la boîte tu peux mettre les
actions d'apprendre dans la boîte tu
peux mettre des FNB dans la boîte c'est
c'est juste un abri dans le fond au
niveau du gouvernement puis on est
limité lorsqu'on peut mettre mais dans
le Code civil c'est cumulatif à partir
de l'âge de 18 ans je pense c'est rendu
à 6000 dollars par année
j'ai comme un blanc là mais en tout cas
ça augmente à toutes les deux trois ans
parce que l'inflation je pense que
c'était un peu plus mais bref mais mais
donc oui quand tout va comme moi quand
je vois dans ma page de ma banque si
j'ai mes comptes faire des crédit puis
en dessous j'ai mes investissements réel
régime épargne études pour mon garçon
donc j'ai toutes ces des lignes
différentes c'est des boîtes différentes
dans ces boîtes là je mets des fonds
négociations en bourse donc je vais
payer de l'impôt lorsque je vais dans le
cas du Real lorsque je sortirai les
sommes dans le code cellule l'impôt il y
a pas d'impôts à payer sur la croissance
puis justement le Celli c'est là-dedans
qu'on a intérêt à mettre des placements
boursiers parce que le placement
boursiers ont énormément de chance de en
fait c'est eux qui ont le plus de chance
de croître à long terme puis c'est ça
que tu veux tuer des fois des gens ils
mettent des certificats de placement
garantis dans leur dans leur cellules
mais c'est un peu ridicule c'est parce
que
l'avantage d'utiliser c'est sur la
croissance à long terme donc tu veux
mettre
ce qu'il y a le plus de chance de de
prendre de la valeur donc justement des
Fonds d'action c'est là que c'est là que
ça va puis dans cinq dix ans 15 ans
c'est une personne qui prendrait sa
retraite avec son cellules c'est le
meilleur hack que tu peux imaginer parce
que
sont tout ce que ça de ce lit est
invisible aux yeux du gouvernement donc
tu es archi pauvre aux yeux du
gouvernement donc si il me semble qu'il
est à sa retraite avec son CÉLI et comme
avoir droit aux plaines rentrante
du Québec puis de tawa parce que ces
personnes-là elle est pratiquement dans
la rue mais à plus vers le fond c'est
millionnaire
admettons comme étant comme un les
chiffres là-dessus mettons que à 65 ans
CÉLI tu fais 9 métaux que tu fais neuf
pour cent de rendement par année tu fais
90 000 par année tu peux sortir cet
argent là il est comme tu as pas
d'impôts à payer dessus c'est ça puis tu
as toutes les avantages de quelqu'un qui
fait zéro exact puis justement là le
décaissement donc tu parles ben en fait
la formule qui est pas mal la plupart
actuellement c'est de prendre 4%
4% du de tes placements pour en vivre
puis ça c'est parce que si tu prends
toute le neuf pour cent tout le temps
par année
pas plus puis éventuellement tu vas tu
vas vider puis te l'inflation aussi
là-dedans donc quand tu prends 4 % donc
ton million mais ça 40 000 selon les
études qui ont été faites tu peux ton
argent va durer 30 ans et plus donc
c'est ça un peu un topilope c'est ça
plus tu vieillis plus tu pourras prendre
un petit peu plus c'est sûr que le 4% il
est conservateur
puis dans la vraie vie les gens
retraités en guillemets ils peuvent
disons si on a un gros crash boursier
ben ils peuvent choisir de mettre moins
d'apprendre cette année-là pour moins
aller en voyage puis ils peuvent jouer
un peu avec ça ça va augmenter tes
chances mais bref les gens retraités ou
même les jeunes retraités c'est souvent
c'est le chiffre qui ont en tête c'est 4
% des actifs
donc 4% les actifs dans le fond ce que
tu fais c'est 25% tes dépenses annuelles
ont des avantages au niveau de l'impôt
justement le réel c'est un foncé tu
repousses le moment où tu payes l'impôt
donc c'est un gros real tu peux prendre
une année sabbatique puis vivre avec
l'argent que tu as dans ton réel parce
que cette année-là tu peux le décaisser
ton taux d'impulsion il va avoir baisser
tu vas payer comme tu retires
l'équivalent de ce que tu fais
d'habitude
le cellier aussi j'entends souvent des
gens dire ah je m'envoi dans le sud je
prends l'argent de mon solide ça me fait
toujours sauter un peu parce que le
séisme comme une Ferrari le titre fautif
faut le Shiner puis en prendre soin
parce que il donne son plus meilleur
rendement à très très longtemps donc si
tu sors de l'argent tu es comme un peu
un compte tchèque tu le remplis tu sors
tu tires un peu dans le pied du
phénomène des intérêts composés donc
t'empêche ton argent de multiplier puis
c'est pour ça que je dis le SELI dans un
monde idéal quand tu es en phase
d'accumulation ça veut dire quand tu
travailles activement tu devrais plus
penser en termes de le remplir plutôt
qu'à l'épiger dedans puis si tu veux
faire un voyage ben c'est épargne à côté
puis bon voyage à côté parce que le
séisme un petit peu tu devrais pas
vraiment touché ça parce que
ces avantages c'est justement sur le
long terme puis c'est le long terme
enfin juste une parenthèse aussi il y a
une phrase qui avait lu c'est que dans
le fond le long terme c'est quoi c'est
juste une série de court terme mais bout
à boutique donc tu as le fond c'est mon
anniversaire est un mail design sur la
montagne ah oui moi je suis à long terme
les placements
je regarde pas ça avant tout ça ok oui
ça c'est un théorie mais en pratique
quand tu regardes tes placements tu vois
que ça a baissé mais ça c'est le court
terme c'est pas l'éviter c'est à moi de
vivre dans une grotte puis de jamais
regarder tes placements ce que je
recommande fortement mais bref des gens
qui sont pas capables
[Musique]
des obligations sur le site sur le côté
aussi vous avez les gens une question
que j'ai aussi beaucoup c'est âge de
m'acheter une maison dans 5 ans ce que
j'ai investi mon argent parce que la
réponse c'est non investi le pas en
faire la bourse parce que 5 ans c'est
assez court terme en fait les choses
sont en ta faveur c'est au niveau le je
pense que c'est 8 fois sur 10 là la
Bourse est en hausse après cinq ans mais
ce serait plate que ça soit dans deux
fois où la bourse en hausse puis là
c'est là que tu as besoin de retirer
donc ce que tu peux faire
il y a des FNB qui sont celui auquel je
pense l'acronyme c'est cash c'est Ash et
c'est des FMB qui te donne un rendement
mensuel sur ton placement puis ça tourne
autour de 5% actuellement ce qui est
tout remonté mais ça va fluctuer si
baisse les taux normalement va baisser
mais dans le fond ça c'est une façon de
dire mettre l'argent de côté pour un
moyen terme
et donc ou sinon il y a des comptes à
intérêts élevés là j'ai pas trop exploré
mais il y a des banques quand je viens
de ce monde là ils ont des ils ont des
offres là
tant d'argent pour tenter tant de temps
donc ça ça peut être quelque chose pour
5 ans et moins
mais la bourse faut vraiment
il faut plus penser en décennies qu'en
année si vous allez avoir des bonnes
années vous allez avoir des mauvaises
années c'est moi ça m'affecte pas j'ai
pas de
réactions face à ça c'est super vite du
jour au lendemain c'est quelque chose
qui s'est bâti avec le long terme mais
c'est plus vous allez vous familiariser
avec le la mécanique ou le marché
respire c'est il monte il baisse il
monte il baisse mais sur 10 ans tu te
retournes puis tu vois le chemin que tu
as parcouru donc c'est plus là dedans
qu'il faut penser à ça c'est comme plus
je sais pas trop une hygiène de vie ou
une façon de juste dire garde
mon salaire me m'enrichit en même temps
en parallèle à ce que moi c'est mes
dépenses de tous les jours mais mon
salaire aussi il se met à travailler
c'est un peu c'est un peu comme ça qu'il
faut le voir plutôt que comme un espèce
de de
plus de bonbons qu'on peut piger tout le
temps c'est parce que là tu tires dans
le pied un peu à ce moment-là parce que
tu empêche le phénomène de
multiplication de fonctionner fait
quelqu'un mettant qui aurait deux
objectifs un épargner au sa retraite
puis deux mettons d'ici 5 ans chez une
propriété devrait faire deux comptes
différents mettons c'est libre pour sa
retraite puis un autre affaire pour sa
maison qui plus sûr qui fluctue moins
exact
encore une fois parce que c'est ça c'est
sur cinq ans c'est
un peu un coup d'épée dans je sais pas
trop
mais personne peut vraiment le dire puis
c'est s'assurer ou même chose avec une
tu veux t'acheter une voiture dans trois
ou quatre ans tu sais que tu as une
grosse dépense qui s'en vient c'est
mélangent à côté tu vas avoir un
avantage tu vas pouvoir le payer cash tu
auras pas de stress tu auras pas de
dette tu vas pouvoir lire le journal tu
vas pouvoir voir les taux d'intérêt de
ça pour avoir tout le monde capoter mais
toi tu vas être comme tu vas être campé
parce que tu seras pas soumis à ça tu
sais mais il y a quand même des
meilleures options qui ont compte check
une faction c'est des obligations
finalement c'est un compte épargne
a intérêt élevé mais là faut voir là
c'est parce que pendant des années était
redevistes comme point 3%
justement les FNB qui te permettent
d'avoir un rendement
demain matin là ça ça peut être un
avantage aussi une personne qui veut
mettre de l'argent côté pour
un imprévu mais là tu veux pouvoir le
vendre facilement là c'est donc
ça peut être un avenir puis plutôt dans
le podcast sans parler de c'est avoir
des fonds et avoir de l'argent de côté
justement pour être capable de payer
quelque chose cash si ça arrive quelque
chose plutôt que de voir emprunter avoir
une marge mais est-ce que c'est toujours
la meilleure option parce que maintenant
je te donne un exemple moi je commence à
à checker pour la chaîne propriété
je pourrais moi mais ton maître dans les
prix que je regarde plus que 20% de mise
à fond sur une propriété mais est-ce que
c'est nécessairement une bonne idée ou
tu es mieux placé cet argent-là puis va
faire plus d'argent en action qu'est-ce
que tu sauves d'intérêt de mettre plus
comment est-ce que je voudrais super
bonne question
dans le fond c'est tout dépend du tout
l'intérêt ok c'est sûr que quand les
taux étaient à 2% mais là on disait au
monde c'est mettre tes enfants pas
beaucoup sur votre maison parce que les
rendements espérés à la Bourse c'est si
on se mettant qu'on les met autour de
7%, on se donne un peu de marge de
manœuvre et tout
la Bourse est intéressante maintenant si
les taux d'intérêt sont plus s'approche
de ce que le rendement Bossier peut te
donner mais là ça devient un peu plus 55
ans c'est un peu selon parfois est-ce
que tu es plus confortable de diminuer
ta dette
ça peut être une bonne idée
une dette c'est un risque tu sais il y a
des gens qui l'apprent à la dure là ces
temps-ci les gens qui renégocient leur
hypothèque c'est dans un an ou dans deux
ans avec les tours qui se passe de 2 à 5
là le budget va prendre un coup
donc ça peut valoir la peine mais c'est
historiquement les les marchés
financiers ont donné de meilleurs
rendements que l'immobilier résidentiel
au moins je peux y toucher c'est du
concrète c'est très très rassurant
mais
d'acheter des actions que d'acheter un
immeuble mais bon il faut voir les
chiffres c'est sûr que au Québec les
loyers sont très bas bah excuse-moi
beaucoup augmenté je pense faire
l'Autriche là mais c'est comparé avec ce
qui est aux États-Unis les loyers sont
quand même assez bas donc la personne
qui achète un immeuble faut que calcul
ses loyers puis il faut qu'elle arrive
comme une entreprise faut qu'elle fasse
plus de profit que de dépenses
donc il y a des gens qui le font très
bien là moi j'ai vraiment pas la bosse
de l'immobilier
mais c'est une façon très correct dans
un marché comme Montréal ou les prix ont
tellement monté les triplex ces choses
là c'est peut-être rendu difficile de
dégager un profit une fois que tu as une
fois que tu as pensé à toutes les
dépenses là moi en tout cas quand je
regarde les chiffres je sais pas comment
le monde fait là à moins de miser sur
l'appréciation de la bâtisse là mais
artistes c'est ça souvent en tout cas en
finance
l'appréciation de la bâtisse ça devrait
être la souris sur Sunday c'est ça
devrait être humaine
superphone mais ça devrait pas être ton
focus principal parce que il y a eu des
périodes dans l'histoire où les bassins
sont pas appréciées pendant 5 10 15 ans
il faut que tu sois prêt à vivre avec ça
aussi
mais ce soit donc moi je te dirais par
rapport à ça je regarde le taux que tu
payes puis ce que tu peux penses faire
dans les marchés boursiers puis il y a
des films qui ont fait des tableaux
donc tu peux comparer ton rendement
espéré puis la durée en tout cas tu peux
soit un peu sur Google il y a des comme
justement
mais une grille un peu préparé mais
encore là c'est du super long terme
parce que tu peux jamais savoir ce que
la dose doit faire dans un an dans 5 ans
même si
c'est c'est illusoire de penser que tu
peux prévoir donc
faut le voir comme ça
ok très intéressant vraiment je vais
aller dans nos enfants
merci beaucoup
puis qui vont récemment ma tête un
bonbon bonbon merci merci de vos
questions c'est aussi intéressant merci